NATO was formally blamed sabotage
for the destruction of the Nordstrom
Pipeline and vowed to collectively
respond with their military Alliance and
members of NATO are outright saying
Russia did it so uh we kind of know
where this is going this could be uh the
burning of the reichstag for Our
Generation or it could be nothing
I was reading about uh Fort Sumter and
one of the things said by uh it was the
Confederate general that they didn't
know if that was going to be a great
battle or just nothing because we really
don't know we are in the thick of it
this could be everything or it could be
nothing so maybe world war three I don't
know you also have the possibility of
war with China because a new report
shows that China's opening police
stations in foreign countries like the
United States Canada and all over Europe
I think they have about 50 police
stations in in Europe why
I don't know it's uh they're saying it's
a violation of international law they're
claiming it's a matter of their own
citizens but that means they're setting
up parallel governance in other
countries even in ours so uh yeah not a
good thing and then considering that the
risks we face with all of this I want to
play for you a video another video
I guess another another video of Joe
Biden getting lost and wandering around
with Mr Burns hands confused as they try
to call out to him and stop him from
wandering away
I I we're just you know what man instead
of being down about it they will order
some wings get some beers some pizzas
and just kick back and watch some some
comedy shows or something joining us
today are actually before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
as a member you will be supporting our
journalists who rely on your generous
memberships to keep doing their jobs
that's how we support the news arm of
timcast but as a member you also get
access to the uncensored after hours
show those goes up those go up at 11 PM
and also cast Castle Tales from the
inverted world then we have more shows
that are currently in development so
it's going to be really really fun and
we're uh we're hiring more journalists
all the time so uh support our work
click join us over at timcast we're
gonna have that members only show up
tonight at 11. don't forget to smash the
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends joining
us to talk about all this is Mark
Housley hello how are you I'm good who
are you who are you well I'm Mark owsley
um I am a white trash former academic uh
host of the unwelcome podcast out of the
state of Oklahoma and you know I'm
fighting undercover wokeness in red
States so thank you for having me here I
really appreciate it right on thanks for
joining us yeah that's good we also have
uh the T-shirt Merchant himself Lou
gradkowski hey guys my name is Luke of
we are change.org and as you know I'm a
very serious person and I wanted to once
again fully really now apologize for my
Antics the last few days they were very
unprofessional it wasn't it wasn't right
for me to say all those things the the
Bill Gates move boom boobs and again I
promise I'll be I'll be a lot more
serious from now on the shirt I'm
wearing right now is also very serious
it reads in a world filled of Lies truth
is always a conspiracy you could get the
shirt on thebestpoliticalshirts.com
because you do I'm here thanks for
having me your Jersey's crooked behind
you I'm sorry let me get that really
quickly
oh
my God
yeah yeah there it is I'm good right now
get this man off flirt that looks better
that looks great really good looking as
I often mentioned there are people who
are just listening to this like not
watching the video and they're like I
have no idea what's happening you should
definitely be watching video narrator
the video yeah we need to get like
someone with like a really deep voice
gigantic butt cheeks knock over a bottle
as he turns to straighten the Jersey
thank you Luke rubkowski thank you also
I'm back after a night off
um desperately just suffering along with
these people in Florida I'm sure I mean
not the way they are unfortunate
unfortunately or unfortunately but man I
feel some pain down there I tried I
meditated it's just I mean what can you
do it's a hurricane and
pretty devastating I'm going to roll a
20-sided die see what kind of recovery I
can bring to this evening I got a I got
a nine maybe it's a six
well either way the night's gonna get
hotter we're gonna say nine yeah so
bundle a lot better mine's better bundle
up like Gavin Newsom in the middle of a
heat wave that's right well tonight's
show is off to a great start thank you
for joining us Mark I'm very excited to
talk about what we have to talk about
tonight let's get going here's the first
story we got from the Wall Street
Journal NATO formerly blamed sabotage
for nordstream pipeline damage military
Alliance says it would be prepared to
defend its infrastructure from attacks
in a ratcheting up of tensions between
Russia and the West it's a little bit
worse than that they said
NATO said the series of leaks in the
north stream pipelines between Russia
and Europe were the result of sabotage
and that attacks on its members
infrastructure would be met with a
collective response from the military
Alliance so let's just say
they're they I'm assuming they're not
talking about Nordstrom but they might
be because Germany relies on it but it's
a weird thing because I'm trying to
figure out what they're trying to say
okay are they blaming Russia for it
directly no but several member states
are
if they are it's very weird that they're
like our adversaries infrastructure was
blown up and we'll retaliate if someone
blows up our infrastructure it's like uh
it sounds like you blew it up and now
you're worried they're going to blow up
yours so I don't know world war three or
what do you think it's it's not a good
geopolitical situation for everyone
involved here everyone's going to lose
everyone's going to suffer the people of
Europe are going to go without energy
Russia is of course already dealing with
a lot of consequences because of the war
the U.S embassy just announced that any
American in Russia should leave
immediately Putin is also set to Annex
large parts of Ukraine which is going to
set the groundwork for a possible
nuclear attack on territory that now he
claims is his and and again it's a messy
situation it's a very complex situation
we should be calling for de-escalation
and sadly all we're seeing on the
corporate media is escalation putting
more fuel on the fire which is dangerous
for everyone and stupid in my opinion it
looks like Vladimir Putin may go with
the zap bran against zap Branigan
strategy strategy are you guys familiar
where he sends wave after wave of his
own men just into the onslaught until it
completely overwhelms now that's a joke
right but that's actually the
traditional Russian strategy it is
historically right so during World War
II so this is amazing I've got a Soviet
um what is it called I think it's called
the p64 I could be wrong I don't know if
you know this is Polish and it was uh
from the cold cold war it is a small
it's a nine millimeter Makarov it's a
handgun and it's ergonomical only for
your right hand which is okay I guess
it's not inclusive and nobody ever wants
to use it at the range you know why it
bites into your head it hurts and so
it's it's it's fun to have these Soviet
bullets these macro bolts but the thing
is when they were making guns they were
like they don't care if it hurts they
don't care if it's made of crap they're
just gonna make a ton of them and crank
them out and give them to everybody and
say go for it so they met I think I
think the story was in World War II they
mass produced a whole bunch of garbage
tanks and then Germany was like we're
gonna make really good tanks that were
really hard to make and then Raja just
storm through with all of them blowing
up and they're like more is better
so yeah it looks like as much as I can
joke about Futurama
without with the conscription of 300 000
men and the reporting that he could even
bring up to 100 up to a million seems
like the annexing of the territory
strategy is going to be okay how many
ukrainians are there screw it just send
300 000 guys there and of men will win
yep well that's all it takes
overwhelming Force that's always been
Russia's main main way of doing things
and that they have very little care for
human life in general and that's that's
what we've seen from Putin over and over
and over again that's what we've seen
for almost every government that is true
that is true but especially the Russians
especially the Soviets that's I mean
when Stalin was just you know Mass
murdering people Mass taking people's
starvation they didn't care about the
people he didn't care about the people
on the ground it's what his overall goal
was because it's it's true but I just
don't think that's unique that's true
you know I mean Barack Obama blew a
bunch of kids no it's not the same as
you know a holiday more or anything like
that yeah so there's certainly people
who are substantially course that I
understand but I just think
you know governments this is what they
do World War one was pure electrician it
was just trench warfare against machine
guns but I think but also in World War
one they used to cut underground
underground cables and and mess with
each other's infrastructure so we have
to understand that this was an act of
War what are going to be the larger
ramifications of it or something that is
dangerous for everyone escalations sorry
no no it's okay no I just think the
higher you get up in the in the Escalon
of things High Atop The Thing the less
you care about the people below you
because you don't see them you don't
deal with them you don't you don't see
what they're doing on the ground you
don't see their families you don't see
that they can't pay their bills that
they can't get groceries they can't get
gas I mean it it's all to varying levels
of degrees but as you get higher up in
in power that's that's how people tend
to look at I think about that with like
the opioid crisis too I hear a lot about
people and like oh and his wife got
addicted to opioids and then she died
and part of me is like wow how stupid
she was and then I realized like if that
was my family member and you see someone
suffering from drug addiction it's no
it's like one of the most suffering like
gut-wrenching horrible painful
experiences because it's so helpless
feeling well but that's especially true
because my both of my parents passed
from no opioid addiction we didn't know
that that's what it was back then we got
to remember where we were at that point
when when my parents were taking
Oxycontin it was because the doctor gave
it to them yeah and and so we didn't
know that they were addicted to those
drugs we didn't know that it's basically
synthetic heroin that you know you can
abuse at any given point and so we
thought it was helping them but it was
really killing them right and so we have
to remember where we were in history at
that point we look back on it now of
course we know it's an opioid crisis of
course we know but the pharmaceutical
companies know but they were high Atop
The thing right they didn't care about
the people on the ground they were
making their money I'm looking at
you know it's funny because we talk we
talk about Civil War the potential for
civil war quite a bit and now the lead
stir we have is that NATO is basically
saying we will respond as a collective I
mean this this is this is the door being
knocked on of the NATO military Alliance
saying we will go to war with Russia but
inside the United States we have a
decrepit decaying demented old man as a
president no one most people don't even
believe he's in charge we've got an
opioid crisis we've got a economic
collapse the Market's tanking it's uh I
don't know where this is going but but
uh I don't is it bad but no Tim
absolutely not we have a great vice
president in Kamala Harris she's a very
strong very thoughtful very intelligent
leader that just signed an official
alliance with North Korea North Korea
will now be fighting officially on our
side according to the vice president of
the United States other statements
earlier on today so in the White House
transcript they struck the word North no
they didn't yeah they did wait did we
actually did she actually sign no no no
no she officially no okay let me explain
this you want to explain this go ahead
no well she she was giving a speech in
front of in front of the cameras and she
said that we have we have great partners
with North Korea we are great partners
with North Korea it was more than that
it was yeah she said something like a
strong military oh yes oh yes she was
like it was like she meant to say
something yeah she did yeah she but you
still don't have to strike that from the
record they Struck it there's a line
through it I think I think this is what
people are posting on Twitter I need to
fact check it but you know yeah well
what do you do you should be striking
that you should I think it was uh Daniel
Turner actually who tweeted it out
because he mentioned that uh in the past
they've actually outright altered the
transcript remember when Biden said
repeat the line yes they were like he
said let me repeat the line no he didn't
no we all heard him what I saw that
Korean jump here podcast I was gonna
call it that one clip where they're like
the reporters are really getting
concerned with Biden's mental health
they're like dude okay but he you know
he did say top of mind about a dead
person he did say where is he did keep
asking for someone that was dead
thinking they were in the room like what
is going on well at least he has an
excuse though that's that's what scares
me about Kamala Harris it's like okay at
least Biden's is an older man right he's
obviously doing a very hard job it's not
hard to be vice president okay I mean
many have said it's not worth the you
know piss in a boot yeah right it's it's
not a hard job but she still has these
very she can't speak correctly you know
you know what meme I really like is the
um
um ah what's that what's that show uh
where Impractical Jokers or something
like what yeah yeah they're all laughing
the guys backstage looking at the screen
making another guy do something yeah so
like we need to make a meme of Kareem
Jean-Pierre and then it's the guys like
okay now just say a bunch of random
words and then she talks and then it's
them laughing it's like it's a master of
improv she's saying random things and
you're like
look I know the whole thing's a
spectacle but like going up there and
not saying proper sentences is just a
chat it makes me angry and I gotta
control my anger it's a total chat move
every day all she would have had to say
to get past that it was go
the president means a lot of people the
president is talking to a lot of people
he didn't remember that that maybe she
had passed away in that moment that's
all she would have had to say just said
he clearly misspoke yes what more of you
if she made an accident accident
happened if she was like yeah I don't
know what's wrong with them would she be
fired the next time
[Laughter]
you understand Ian like phrasing it that
way is actually like one of the worst
possible ways to phrase it yeah but
would she be fired would she like the
next day would they have a new speaker
if she was no better no no because she
was you know it would be one of the
greatest days in American history no she
should get honest for a minute and save
the Republic could you imagine if
someone a reporter was like just today
the president called out to a deceased
geo-representative why would he do that
that's why I feel like a press secretary
Michael malice would be so much fun oh
yes because he just say like something's
wrong with him you know you asked him
world war three and civil this these
world war three and Civil War during
World War One the Russians had a civil
war so like it can be both at once
that's really what concerns me if that
if some crazy War breaks out overseas in
Europe and Asia as if we think it's
going to stay there that then there
would be chaos internally it's like dude
you saw the Communist Revolution brought
a century of murder and Decay and then a
split up into what they have now which
is no Black Sea access like they've had
to fight to try and get back access to
the Mediterranean because after the
Soviet Union was split up whoever the
oligarchs were that chose who got what
said no Russia's not going to get
sevastopol it's they're too strong we
want to block them off from the
Mediterranean but Russia did have uh
that they have a naval base there and so
they were like okay this is part of
Ukraine but we don't care that Russia
uses it and people there speak Russian
that's why Russia moved in and take it
when Ukraine was was entertaining
joining the EU or NATO and they're
trying to give Don best make it
autonomous at least this is what Dave
Smith was saying on Rogan was the the
word on the street when they were
negotiating a peace deal Ukraine and
Russia is like we're gonna make Don best
the Eastern version of Ukraine
autonomous I don't know if that means
give it back to Russia keep it as
Ukrainian make its own State make it
independent and no NATO troops in
Ukraine as pre-decided before 2014 after
the fall the Soviet Union it was decided
we're not going to put NATO forces on
Russia's border because now Russia's are
good now now that the Soviet Union's
gone they can be a federation to work
with us
and um tell me but NATO's NATO's just
been expanding yeah and now they're now
they're now Finland potentially joining
so it's funny because I was reading one
article and it said Russia's unprovoked
invasion of Ukraine and I'm just like
okay first of all that's just an opinion
piece right like unprovoked you can
argue that NATO expansion was a
provocation You could argue it wasn't
you can argue whether or not a country
wants to join NATO Russia still has no
right to invade Ukraine but there's
certainly I I don't know if provocation
is the right word but there are reasons
behind why these things are happening
this is a complicated matter that goes
back decades and has been escalating
slowly and surely and many people saw
everything coming many people saw the
writing on the walls uh Putin is set to
give a speech tomorrow specifically
about this uh particular event about his
annexation of now more Ukrainian
territory as his troops look like
they're also losing in a very important
key city of Lyman right now and it's
also important to note here uh from a
lot of the videos and a lot of the
photos some of it is propaganda but it
doesn't look like the Russians are
having a lot of military success inside
of Ukraine and when you look at the
photos when you look at the videos it's
it's overwhelmingly a lot of Russian
Hardware being destroyed so you know
just seeing that just just highlights
you know the situations getting
desperate this is a complicated
situation we don't know who to believe
everyone's lying from each side here
there's a lot of disinformation there's
a lot of propaganda and it's going to be
interesting to see what he will announce
tomorrow as I will be keeping keeping a
very close eye on it well and there's a
lot of money being made by replenishing
everything that's being blown up yeah
you know and that's that's that there's
a that comes down to it man it's always
hey how can we get more and more stuff
in there more and more billions of
dollars worth of Munitions so we can put
more and more in there when it gets
blown up that's what we're talking about
the pipeline my first thought was CIA
second thought was corporations like the
corporations that are profiting off of
the war right the the so this new Baltic
pipeline who whoever is running gas
through there has a real good interest
in taking away leverage from Russia but
I want to say one last thing on on this
you know look right now we're dealing
with a whole lot in this country with
the with the hurricane
and uh there's a lot of damage down
there so that's why it's very very
important that we have a a decisive
president who takes the initiative and
sends tremendous relief to Ukraine
oh my gosh yeah the billions of dollars
over there it's gonna do it's gonna be
great for all of the uh suffering
Americans because you know while they're
down in Florida looking at their lives
being completely destroyed in their
hearts they will be warmed knowing that
ukrainians have guns well that's that's
Equity right yeah I mean it's Global
Equity but it's still Equity right and
also you know surface-to-air missiles
which are finding their way on their
black market so you know that's that's
also really nice to have all over Europe
with fully automatic machine guns also
hitting the black market all over Europe
which is absolutely crazy to send so
much money so much weapons with no
accountability at all I'm gonna pull up
this story here from U.S news fears
about World War III are growing amid
Russia Ukraine war survey funds gee I
wonder why well the pope said we are in
World War III but this is interesting
stuff
they said uh Russia oh here we go look
at this Russia's unprovoked war with
Ukraine and I'm just like is this an
op-ed or is it a survey okay the
provocation for people to get references
like if Russia had a military base and
this is what Dave Smith said again in
Montreal and they were just they took it
over and then they were establishing
military forces and long-range missiles
in Montreal and then for us to go in and
be like no no no we're taking it back
we're liberating it that would have been
and to say that it was unprovoked of us
to go back into going to Montreal when
Russia had been building up there that's
provocation
I want to read the story they say in a
survey of more than 70 000 people across
the world three quarters of respondents
agreed with the statement I fear we are
moving closer to World War III the
findings are called from the U.S news
and World Report best country survey
yada yada it's from April 30th July 13th
this survey was done before all of this
went down the craziest part is this
eighty percent of those in five
countries Indonesia South Korea Spain
Thailand and the US believed that we are
heading towards a global war those
surveyed within the age range of 25 to
35 were the most fearful with 76
worrying about Nations moving closer to
another global conflict
so
you know what
what I think about when I see this
we always we always read history and
it's condensed and now we don't know
which direction things will go but I
suppose the question I have is are
things de-escalating the answer the
answer is a resounding no especially
with NATO saying we will as a collective
respond to an attack on our
infrastructure which here's what I think
it sounds like what they're saying
NATO forces Western forces Western
aligned interest uh interests destroyed
the pipeline
and that statement was Russia if you
retaliate we will go to war with you
that's exactly what it was and and and
then trotting out Biden having said this
just a few months ago that if if they
invade Ukraine we're going to get the
pipeline they can point it right back at
us and he gave them that's another
example of not having a president that
knows what he's saying when he's saying
it yeah well before you know the
president said it the deputy secretary
of state Victoria Newland said this I
just did a video about her she's a
fascinating human being she's known as
the kind of uh the the lady of the
neoconservatives Miss Dick Cheney likes
she served under uh Dick Cheney during
the Iraq War she had her hand in almost
every single U.S Global intervention in
the past 30 years and she said in
January that if Russia invades Ukraine
Russia will not be having the Nordstrom
2 pipeline one way or another yeah and
then and then uh Biden came out and and
I think think made that particular
statement that that you're referring to
no no no no Newlin said one way or
another there will not be a nordstream
pipeline and uh and Joe Biden said there
will not be
a Nord stream if Russia invades Ukraine
then our reporter follows up and says
how would you do this controlled by
Germany and he says uh I promise you we
will get it done and it just marks yeah
and and this is earlier this year right
right before the invasion right before
the war and even Salon came out and
wrote an article saying how appointing
Victoria Newland to Obama's foreign
policy team was quote a really bad idea
if she's going to be a key player in his
foreign policy because it's a high risk
to everyone so even Salon even leftist
news organizations were saying hey
please let's not appoint her to
positions of power because this is going
to lead to chaos this is going to lead
to war she literally had her hand in
almost every single conflict the last 30
years and for her to to still be calling
the shots she's also known as the lady
that was organizing protests and working
as a diplomat overseeing the Ukrainian
revolution in 2014. I did a full video
about this it's fascinating to see her
hand in this entire conflict from the
very beginning pushing the envelope and
I think we're we're reaching a situation
where that envelope is about to fall off
of the table uh because she is really
going for it when it comes to
instituting American policy that has put
us on this pathway since 2014 that is
extremely dangerous for everyone here
here's a question that I have when it
comes to this stuff
is it worth war with Russia
question what do you think is is any of
this worth the potential of a nuclear
war no no none of it's worth it to us
now hold on so let me ask you a question
let's uh localize the conflict wokeness
all right
uh we're in a culture War something that
we are particularly worried about
is it worth the culture War to stop what
they're doing to kids in the
indoctrination
yes even if it leads to Civil War
even if it leads to Civil War if if we
are looking down the barrel of overt
Civil War
is there a point where you would say I
accept I am willing to lay down my arms
to prevent War knowing that it means the
woke people will win and their gender
ideology and the things that haven't
happened with kids will increase tenfold
would you lay down you know no well I
think I think when you're talking about
innocence when you're talking about
innocent children and and what what
adults want to go to this and then
there's a line there you know there's a
moral line where you can say no I'm not
I'm going to pick up my arms right so my
point is not to in any way insinuate
people should be fighting they shouldn't
be it's a question of when when we
localize the issues that we care about
when we think about in the context of
something that we're directly you know
more directly concerned about we as
people
um you know living and working in the
United States and very focused on
domestic issues we don't know the full
scale of the war
what we do know is that I don't want to
die for whatever BS they're working on
with Ukraine right the issue I suppose
is understanding that feeling you have
of I will not I will not back down in
this culture war in in this political
battle with what the left is doing with
all this work ideology stuff they won't
the same is true for what the US and
Russia are doing it's it's a question
that you can go to Western intelligence
say is it really worth it why don't you
just let Russia do their thing because
otherwise we have nuclear war and
they're going to say we will not stand
for this Russia will be asked the same
question absolutely not we will never
lay down our arms
and then it's just dominoes falling over
where you and everyone ends up losing
it's a pissing contest everyone just
covered in Piss but what what is the US
goal here I mean because I think I think
the Russian goal is at least a bit more
plainly clear they don't want to see
just like they agreed to in 2014 the
build up in Ukraine right where that we
agree way more complicated you know well
I know I know it's more complicated
Russia's trying to rebuild the Soviet
Union basically yeah I know that yeah I
know but what is and so the goal of the
United States is to keep that from
happening right and and and partly
because gas prom controls most of the
pipelines talking to you I think they
really want the Soviet Union back again
oh Putin's talked about it yeah but he
just we just went and sat down with um
who was he sitting down with and he was
like he said something like remember who
you uh work for or something like that I
can't remember yeah he Putin also sees
NATO as a legitimate threat against
Russia and its people as well as well as
trying to bring back the old kind of
Soviet Empire as well so we have to
understand that also the larger
geopolitical picture is complicated
because of the new energy X exploration
that has been done in the southern coast
of Ukraine that has found that Ukraine
could soon become a major major Petro
state if Ukraine becomes a major Petro
State the one leverage that Russia has
in all of Europe is totally gone they
will have a competitor on its doorsteps
that will also house a lot of its troops
that they see as someone that will
potentially invade them in the future so
there's a lot of things happening here
behind the scenes there's a lot of
things geopolitically also with energy
policy that people need to understand
and it's far more complicated than just
unprovoked attacked it's not just that
there's Freedom involved here they hate
us for our freedom exactly I think the
goal is like Global Security if you had
to ask what's the U.S goal here not as
much not the the number one top goal
isn't just prevent the Soviet Union from
forming it's Global Security and part of
doing that is to prevent a Soviet Union
but honestly we need to police ourselves
and we can do that with Russia as a
Federation of states of people like
they're just people like us they have a
red white and blue flag they broke up a
crazy dick-tocratic State uh just like
we got out of the the kingdom of England
uh we're in this together we're not we
are as people on Earth breathing the
same air and drinking the same water you
have people who fundamentally view the
world differently than each other and
there is no reconciling well that will
always be the case and that's view it
differently reconciliation is do we want
you live you just deal with it that's
what we've done for 250 years you don't
right now there are uyghur concentration
camps in China we do not lay down and
accept what China is between these
people we are no and we have for like a
decade the United States is is is is
doing what they can I suppose without
with with trying to avoid war this is
the point I'm trying to make with even
Civil War United States we don't want to
fight yeah we don't want people to die
but we need this to stop so we're
constantly clashing with opposing forces
that view the world fundamentally
differently than we do and there is no
just stopping and saying you know what
we're all people China why don't you
just forcibly rape those women and we
want to learn the language
whole America first thing is ridiculous
this old line of demarcation calling us
the West it's all British Centric like
come on you got to learn Russian and
Mandarin if we want to if we want to
peacefully resolve this stuff well that
is there is a good point there because I
name name a Chinese Diplomat that
doesn't know English you know what I
mean that that's something I've always
thought about when you're when you're
talking about speaking I I worked with
Chinese students for example they knew
exactly what I was saying when I was
saying it how I was saying the
connotation you know the the things
behind it and when they would speak
nothing and and when they would try to
translate some of their things uh some
of the things they would say in their
language to me I couldn't quite get what
they were saying and they knew it and
that that that is that is a good point
that we need to maybe Branch out at
least our understanding of what other
languages we're speaking so we can make
an attempt at least to try to understand
where they're coming from but that
doesn't mean we can accept ever that
that you know uh atrocities that that
are that's it's like going on in China
with with the uyghurs and with the women
that they abuse and with I mean there's
videos of them running over running over
old women in in tanks and things like
that it's just but at the same time you
know the Chinese are answering back like
okay you're making these accusations
against concentration camps what about
what you did in gitmo what about the CIA
rendition programs and we're seeing
Chinese diplomats answer answer that
back and at least American policy should
exemplify and practice the principles
that it preaches to bring on to other
people and then those arguments would be
more legitimate but of course there is a
lot of criticism when it comes to
foreign policy when it comes to the
military-industrial complex when it
comes to corporations and private
industries that have been creating
massive amounts of human rights
violations especially in Yemen
especially all over the the Middle East
that again should be called out as well
stopped immediately if we're going to be
lecturing other countries about human
rights but rest easy my good friend Luke
because right now we can all huddle up
to the warm bosom of Joe Biden knowing
that with his strength America will not
be defeated like uh this video for
instance from disclosed TV let me just
uh make sure the audio is configured
properly which is not and then we'll
play this video for you
thank you thank you Mr President
okay let me try that again thank you so
look at it look over here look at this
thank you oh oh no where's he gone
[Applause]
away it looks like an episode of The
Office yes yeah it does man you really
could this really could be a sitcom it's
kind of like Veep or something well it's
somebody's got to make fun of it
sometime soon in a in a formal way but
look here I have I have a legitimate
question see his hands look at this look
look at uh oh yeah you tweeted this out
earlier this is great see his hands
I I remember you know when I'm a kid Mr
Burns he walks around with his hands
like this and I thought it was just like
that's Mr Burns it's something funny and
you see Joe Biden doing this I'm like is
that something that people actually do
when they get old maybe it's like a
balance issue because if their arms are
swinging at the sides you lose balance
easier maybe and so they keep them nice
and tight to the chest I've seen this in
old people yes it's kind of weird right
I never thought about it until just now
but they definitely walk like a little
well maybe they could catch themselves
Mr President thought he was about to
topple well I'm remembering remember
remember he fell trying to grab the
dog's tail right you hurt himself
he maybe learned his lesson you know
he's gonna be really careful yeah I
don't know man but uh to get serious I
would just like to apologize for the
joke opening the segment because no we
are not going to rest easy with this
President you know look man when I wake
up to the news that NATO is like yeah
that was sabotage and we will destroy
our enemies or they didn't say it like
that but you know they said they'll
collectively retaliate I'm like this is
a major historical moment where the NATO
military Alliance says formally that we
will enter the war against you and like
we know what that means and I'm just
like and Joe Biden is the president and
I'm thinking of videos like this there's
a video where remember when he was like
doing the Cornholio thing on CNN there's
all the gibberish words and you know for
a while the media kept trying to act
like he was fine and these left
activists and these Democrat activists
were like he's totally sharp he's
totally with it it's Trump who's crazy
and they can't anymore now we have the
funny thing is not only is Joe Biden's
brain not working but the reporters try
talking to Karine Jean Pierre and she
just says a bunch of random words and
now it's like at a certain point I think
regular people and these journalists are
kind of like
I don't think anybody's at work right
like I don't it's like imagine you go to
a an Applebee's and you walk in and
there's just like nobody and you're like
hey what's going on they're like sup and
you're like I'm hungry and like cool
it's good are you open no okay you'd
leave right but this is the government
this is our country at a time of an
escalating towards war with potentially
China with Russia an economic collapse
but you know what
you know what I can probably maybe I'm
putting the cart before the horse here
maybe the issue is the reason we're
close to war with Russia and China and
there's an economic collapse is because
this man is our president yes and it's
not it could have been a lot of
different people that would have gotten
us here but he's one of them and it's
because his kids and working in barisma
in Ukraine it's some Energy company he
was heavily involved with Obama during
the coup in 2014 in Ukraine that where
they tried to get the Ukraine to go side
with America and the liberal economic
order instead of Russia very explicitly
this is old Colbert uh this is a great
this came up on the Dave Smith Joe Rogan
episode again and I don't have the guy's
name uh this old you know I'm gonna look
into this and pull up the name in a
little bit but they've been planning
this for like two decades at the very
least at the very least and Biden has
been involved in it since the beginning
or at least since the Obama
Administration and there's too much for
him to lose if it gets found out how
much he's been involved putting his son
on the board of an energy company
to get to get there then to switch sides
in the the information is out there the
information is out there and it's there
for playing I just can't imagine my my
father and my grandfather allowing this
that's that's what's really ticking me
off about this really we're allowing
this to happen we're allowing this
bumbling you know systemic problem
throughout the the upper echelons of our
government and we just look at it it's
like yeah you know why not ultimately
we're the ones that are supposed to hold
these people accountable and I see none
of that from the media or not none but
not near as much as you should have and
why are we allowing this let me give you
one of my favorite Wikipedia articles of
all time it is the Biden Ukraine
conspiracy theory article let me read
for you this opening line the Biden
Ukraine conspiracy theory is a series of
false claims centered on the baseless
allegations oh they said false animates
that while Joe Biden was vice president
the US he engaged in corrupt activities
relating to the employment of his son
Hunter Biden by the Ukrainian Gas
Company barisma they were spread
primarily in attempts to damage Joe
Biden's reputation during the 2020
presidential campaign U.S intelligence
Community analysis released in March
2021 found the proxies of Russian
intelligence promoted and laundered
misleading and unsubstantiated
narratives about the bidens to U.S media
organizations U.S officials and
prominent U.S individuals including some
close to the former president from
president Trump and his administration
now over here on the right is a picture
it says Victor shoken one of the primary
subjects of the conspiracy theory the
conspiracy theory alleges that then Vice
President Joe Biden withheld loan
guarantees to pressure Ukraine into
firing shoken to prevent a corruption
investigation into barisma and to
protect his son Hunter Biden let's slow
down real quick and break down what's
wrong with this paragraph we'll go step
by step Victor shoken prosecutor he
exists he is in fact subject of the
story all right next sentence it alleges
then Vice President Joe Biden withheld
loan guarantees
he did on video bragging about how he
did next they say to pressure Ukraine
into firing shoken he did it's on video
him saying so SOB guy gets fired they
say to prevent a corruption
investigation into barisma full stop
it did the firing of Victor shoken which
Joe Biden bragged about did result in
the ending of I think 12 active
investigations check Matt taibi's
reporting on this we we all know what's
happening now this question of did Joe
Biden pressure Ukraine into firing
Victor shulkin yes he did but did he do
it specifically to stop this corruption
investigation that we don't know but it
did stop the corruption investigation
how about that they called a conspiracy
theory by injecting one percent into the
story intent what we know is Biden did
threatened to withhold illegally I might
add loan guarantees did get the
prosecutor fired the fire of the
prosecutor did result in an end to
investigations into barisma and that did
have the added effect of protecting
Hunter Biden now I call that plain and
simple a conflict of interest that alone
warrants in my opinion some kind of
inquiry investigation or hearing to get
to the bottom of how that happened
because there is a question of the
intent but you know what I don't know
his intent to call that whole thing a
conspiracy theory what you're actually
saying to me is it's probably true and
you're terrified that we found out what
would happen if it was Donald Trump and
his sons doing business well
yeah I'm triggered Loop go ahead Donald
Trump sees the video on Twitter of Joe
Biden being like I said we got fired and
so Donald Trump's on the phone with the
president of Ukraine like what is this
video I mean read the transcripts
hilarious he's like what's this video
about withholding why don't you look
into this and they impeached him over it
yeah he accidentally discovered a quid
pro quo so they blamed him for the quid
pro quo and then claimed he was trying
to dig up dirt on his president on his
political rival even though Joe Biden
wasn't running for office at the time
and that's a preemptive narrative I mean
it's a preemptive narrative it's
accusing your enemy of what it is that
you were doing and and they use that
just to keep just to keep themselves out
of out of the alumni Because by the time
you get back to them by the time you
figure out yeah you were you were the
ones actually doing what you accused all
of it it's like my my father used to say
this it's a really good analogy you know
if you burn your hand on an iron it
hurts really really bad the first time
but if you do it 50 times eventually you
can't feel it anymore true you know and
that's and that's that's exactly what
they do with this stuff and they do it
to protect corrupt people and it's it's
plainly visible I just wish that we
could you know get some of the feeling
back in our callous uh Minds on the
subjects and and do something about it I
got the name this guy's name is oh you
got to grab your microphone Gideon rose
on Stephen Colbert Report back in the
day there's a video of Gideon rose on
the Colbert reports talking about the
plan to get Ukraine away from Russia and
take it to the United States it's like
in 2008 2009 and it is so overt he's
blatantly like yes think of it as like
they're the robin to to Russia's Batman
and we got to get Robin to be on our
side and not on Batman's side so he's
basically saying we're the Joker yeah
good call I guess we're the Scarecrow
unless you want to argue like we are
Green Lantern or no we're we're Green
Arrow and we want Robin to join us and
be our new Speedy but also just to come
back to the original topic of this story
I I think Joe Biden is definitely
putting his hand in the cookie jar he's
definitely profiting off of this but I
don't think he's calling the shots here
I think this has been going on way
before Biden became president of the
United States I think there are shadowy
powers behind the scenes instituting a
lot of these plans and I don't think
Biden's in charge he made a steep he
made a statement in Poland a couple of
months ago saying Putin could can't stay
in power the White House had to walk it
back and said and said he didn't mean
what he said he said recently we're
going to defend Taiwan the White House
had to make a statement saying no we
don't actually stand by that whatever
Biden says the White House corrects him
on who's correcting him who's making
sure that the policies of the United
States are not the policies of the
commander-in-chief there is something
else behind the scenes organizing
orchestrating a lot of this and him
being senile him being old I think it's
all a show it's all a play so he could
be the Fall Guy for the larger agenda
that's being shoved down everyone's
throat but why did Obama make him why
did Obama put Ukraine in his portfolio
though
well did he have those connections
before he was vice president or did he
make this connection because he was well
he was also on the senate senate
intelligence committee he was also a
longtime Senator so he had his hands in
a lot of foreign policy in a lot of
contracts in a lot of business dealings
between China and all these other
Kazakhstan countries all throughout the
world so so he was a man who of course
had intelligence connections and had his
hands everywhere but it looks like
barisma was very pro-russia before the
Ukraine flipped in 2014 and so the way
for barisma to be like hey America we
want to be on your side they were like
we'll just take like our Point man their
point man was Biden he was the guy we'll
just take his son on our board and that
way we'll make sure we're on the up and
up we'll we'll profit wasn't there a
former CIA director and a CIA guy was on
there too yeah on prisma's board yeah
that was their way of of snuggling up to
the to the United States After the
Revolution you can call it
um Luke I think you're right that Biden
not calling the shots like we think he
is or that a lot of people think is and
Trump wasn't either he would try to get
the troops out of the Middle East I
think out of Syria particularly and they
did what they call Shell games where the
military is like yeah we have they were
lying to him about the numbers of troops
so he's like okay then I guess we've
reached our number of withdrawals
they're like yeah that's right that's
right and they weren't doing what they
were told well okay it was a former
director of counter-terror Joseph Cofer
black who was uh I believe he was on the
board he was yes he was on the board so
I I I think he's the CIA guy I don't
think it was uh direct or anything well
and I'm going back to your point of the
uh he was director of congressism
specifically so going back to your point
of Biden being kind of the the shell guy
you know I just keep going back in my
mind to that to Obama saying you know if
I could just have a third term where I
wasn't taking all the the arrows and I
could just put somebody up there do all
the you know take all the the crap that
I got for all these years and just make
the decisions behind the scenes that's
what I would really like to do I just
keep going back to that and it makes
very it makes a lot of sense yeah but
Obama wasn't that big of a Warhawk when
it came to Ukraine he was he was afraid
to send lethal weapons to you but was
that because he didn't want to be or is
it because he couldn't be
um that's a good question I don't know
I'm not in his mind but but we know he
was very soft uh on Ukraine
comparatively to a lot of the other
neoconservative hawkish policies that
were pushed on by previous and
predecessor administrations that were
more heavy-handed and escalated tensions
even more than he did but but he even
when he came out of office said I I
regret being so uh hawkish he regretted
the drone strikes so so again I'm not
trying to give him any favors I thought
he was a horrible president just like
every president just like every
politician because I don't trust any
government I don't trust any politicians
and I think naturally people shouldn't
be trusting anyone in our political
landscape right now all of these people
do not deserve your trust do not deserve
your attention do not deserve your
energy if enough of us would would see
politics like this I don't think we
would be in this mess right now because
we wouldn't be giving them all of our
power all of our money all of our
authority to do this nonsense that
they're doing right now I wanna I wanna
pull up the story we did brush on this a
little bit but we have it here from
timcast.com America shares strong
alliance with North Korea VP Harris says
White House plays damage control the
White House appears to have removed
Harris's mention of North Korea in an
official transcript Harris mistakenly
made the claim during her first trip to
the demilitarized zone separating North
and South Korea this week let's play the
video here for you guys so the United
States
shares a very important relationship
which is an alliance with the Republic
of North Korea
and it is an alliance that is strong and
enduring
somebody go well now here's why this is
important right we I mentioned we brush
on this but I got to bring it up because
the deeper issue here is
I've often ragged on Joe Biden for
saying Libya when he meant Syria and the
danger of misspeaking is to public
capacity yeah there are people around
the world who just heard this and I
wonder what impact that will have on a
lot of things because think about it
this way what if kamalaris actually were
to come out and say we are proud to say
that we have a strong alliance with
North Korea and she meant it like Kim
Jong-un comes here and he's like I want
to do a deal and open up trade and and
work with you guys let me know what to
do and it was a tremendous historic
moment the problem is when she said this
everyone immediately went she sang the
wrong word she met South Korea and the
scary thing is we cannot trust in what
they're saying
I think it's going to have a major
impact on
economics on war and conflict peace
treaties it could except that she's the
vice president but what I see in this is
if CNN would have been doing covered the
same instance and it were Donald Trump
or even Mike Pence they wouldn't have
used the word mistakenly right you know
what I mean that's what that's what hits
me and I see this it's really bad in
local media they would say he lied yeah
they would say he lied in the lines of
North Korea or that he wants an alliance
with North Korea and he's going to do it
tomorrow that's that's the difference I
see here at least at least they had the
Integrity to say hey she mistakenly said
this but hey it's kind of funny we we
should maybe ask her about it and clear
it up you know
yeah I think it's amazing uh I'm
wondering if we have the uh well it was
removed the transcript I thought that
was actually really hilarious because
what I saw was like a strike through
like them just being like whoopsie we
didn't mean to say that think about this
what this what this would mean though if
Kamala Harris is going to meet with
someone in private and she says
something like this and then are they
supposed to assume that when she has a
word she's wrong
well they do it with Joe Biden all the
time this is the thing though how old is
Kamala Harris she's in her 40s or what
50s she's in her 50s right yeah early
50s early 50s and she is also sundowning
yeah she's having the same cognitive
decline well why is she wearing
something they're eating like what if
you know I feel really bad about this
like what if Biden actually was really
sharp but Putin was putting poison
slowly in their food and so like we're
sitting here laughing at him mocking
them and they're really just slowly
being wasted Away by yeah someone say
Polonia or something she's 50 50. she's
like 50s yeah she's 57 okay 58 October
20th
you know so uh I don't know if
impeaching or 25th amendmenting Joe
Biden's Gonna Save Us guys but I also
think you know she wants that bride to
begin with yeah so so yeah the effects
are evident earlier in life if you
weren't that bright she's not known for
you know yeah she's not a good public
speaker she was is she losing her she's
very smart like does she have like a
high IQ but I can make some puns there
but I'm not because she's she's worked
away a mature adults yeah well she's
worked her way that's one way to say it
she has worked out Williams you know
one-handed
working she did I think that brilliant
reference did a lot of work Brilliance
is communicative and so is stupidity and
and having a a president that's if you
act like that's normal what Joe Biden's
acting like then then people are going
to start acting like that because they
think it's normal remember the kids will
be like oh that's how I'm supposed to be
remember Freedom oh goodness another
complete fabrication I know another
complete fabrication
yeah this is what politicians do lie
some of them are not good liars she is
not a good liar she's not witty she's
not fast with it she can't play with it
but if Joe Biden's taking a nap and
we're being bombed she's gonna go in the
War Room North Korea
that's that's the type of people in
charge right no it's theater if I was
ever in politics I would either be
brutally honest or just absurdly deceit
deceptive to the point where it's
obvious so it's just like lie in the
most outrageous ways just so you can be
like you you know politician's a liar
right yes that's probably one way to do
it because if you go and try to be
honest they'll accuse you of lying
you'll say something like look we've got
a huge problem right now with this
pipeline what they're doing is I said
otherwise they're like ah you're full of
it you're lying I just feel like aliens
oh yeah a UFO was right overhead we all
saw it and they'd be like whoa whoa
they're admitting it now this is the
crazy thing right if you say something
about Ray just people go they admitted
it yeah but if you say something
seemingly normal they're like nah you
got to be lying I expect an outrageous
story explaining what's really going on
what is it what is it that is breaking
our brains to that end you know what I
mean yeah our brains well not our brains
but you know Collective the world
especially the United States it seems
that what what you're describing there
is is so endemic in in our society that
we can't believe a blatant truth we
poison we can't believe it high fructose
in 92 we started poisoning and then
those people had kids so it's like the
second generation of poison idiocracy
this year is basically we're looking at
something like that it's terrifying
phthalates and it's plastics it's high
fructose it's probably radiation
vegetable seed oils this is a glass
bottle right here
we have we do have plastic water bottles
here but I get a lot of glass bottles
and then we also have refillable glass
bottles too because we have purified
well water with added minerals yeah I
think it's the Plastics computer
monitors all that radiation staring at a
monitor or even just the Adderall and
and all the stuff you're giving
pharmaceutical company right the
companies there's five insurance
agencies running the global medical
industry right now what pcbs poly
chloride biphenols is that what it
stands for yeah I know it's biphenol I
think the couple generations of that in
our bloodstreams is screwing with our
brain yeah it's the generational effect
so like the parents are all messed up
from it and the Obesity but then they
have kids who immediately start using it
when they're little and before that it
was lead and it was lead I mean that
lowered IQ yeah
fluoride yeah I mean it's time to go
live in the woods and just live off of
purified and you know get your own
charcoal carbs out of your diet for 10
days I mean you'll feel like you're
you're burning inside for about on day
five on but after day 10 it's out of you
like clear and then if you start eating
bread again it's so easy to kick it once
you've done it once that didn't happen
to me when I when I cut the carbs out
really I didn't notice anything I had a
horrible pain you lost weight throbbing
I mean I lost a lot of weight really
fast but I wasn't go I wasn't I think I
wasn't no headaches it's just normal in
fact within a few days I just instantly
felt better I also cut the sugar out I
did it in one in a 10-day period because
I Was preparing for an Ayahuasca fast
and they have a specific diet so like no
low salt no sugar no carb and I was like
day five I was on my body was on fire
but I just toughed through it and by day
10 I felt phenomenal I think Kamala and
Joe need to go on like an Ayahuasca
guided trip
just head out to Delaware you know and
just do a little make a dose of
mushrooms what am I doing
yeah see North Korea for a year or if
they want to fight a war bring them on a
retreat right be like hey you're going
to do high doses of mushrooms acid the
LSD DMT whatever you have to do one of
those afterwards if you still want to
fight each other and you want a war you
guys got to fight it yourselves sorry
duel it out figure it out yourselves man
on man uh one one on woman doesn't
matter why don't do it why don't we do
that what movie was it um was it uh Troy
where it's like yeah instead of going to
war that's your best fighters will fight
and then absolutely and that future can
happen if we didn't put all of our faith
in government but nobody can happen
unless you nominate a champion and then
it's like I hope you win because I don't
want to live by their rules like oh we
lost but oh well no fighting I like that
you're encouraging me not to put my
faith in government because I think
directly appealing to the Russian people
is the way to go you're listening right
now and I hear you I'm with you people
you're in Russia you citizens are
listening right now I know it and we got
your back man none of us want this war
as a Russian guy he's like they're
talking about the moon
we're on Earth together right now in
this moment you're listening yeah yes
Vlad you don't have to comply Vlad it's
okay is that like the most common name
in Russia or something pretty much yeah
it can also be like this Muhammad you're
watching the show but I I'm done
appealing to the the politicians for
this solution it's the people it's
bottom up man we got to work together I
got it Dave you forgot to take the
garbage out
Dave is very happy that you mentioned
that right now his wife will also be
very happy don't forget your anniversary
Eric you're pleasing a lot of people
tonight I'm already in super chats and
people are going to be alive whoa your
view is just Skyrocket all the Eric's
and all the devs all the muhammads and
vlads come together and World War and
kamalas yeah there you go yeah yeah man
it feels like
the the issue I think with this war
stuff someone super chatted something
like this that the liberal International
economy needs to be stopped and that's
what Russia is doing but I think that's
just propaganda still I don't think I
don't think Vladimir Putin is some noble
guy who's like no the New World Order is
bad and Must Be Stopped I'm the yeah
right he's got his own interests he's
got his own agenda he's got his own
ideology you've got competing ideologies
I'll tell you this though I don't like
the world economic Forum people in the
Davos group they're crackpots and
they're psychotic so I don't want to
root for anybody other than hey we
shouldn't go to war we should mind our
own business and we we really should not
go to war because we could find
ourselves in a Goblin King state where
people are vying for power and just
killing each other trying to take the
throne over and over and over and over
and again not want to live in that realm
everyone always says you know what would
happen if there was no government people
say Warlords would take over what are we
living through right now well I guess
Warlords have taken over they're taking
over and they're pushing for war but
most of the earth is not an in Conflict
right now you know I mean we're sitting
right here having a conversation so I
mean there's at least some structure
that gives us now where where are we
heading that direction it seems that way
it sure does seem that but but the
possibilities of Calamity and the
destruction of the entire world is there
because of the technological
advancements because of the military
hardware that is out there that could
literally wipe this entire planet off of
the out of the universe so that that you
know but we've been living with that
since 1940 yeah
it would be like chaotic like right now
there's the technological advancements
in nuclear weapons well I know I know
it's gotten I know but I'm just saying
we've been and they've been pushing it
right along but we've been living with
that and better angels have prevailed up
to this point but it seems like we have
the all of these forces just pushing us
more and more and multiple different
levels into more and more conflict
because you were talking about if we had
a World War III I'm I'm really concerned
like you were saying that we would that
America wouldn't be unified like they
were at 9 11 or we were in 1945 or at
the beginning in the Vietnam War even we
would have our own Sub sub Civil Wars
while this other war was going on
someone in the comment section told me
to go to mogandishu I did I went to
Mogadishu Somalia just to talk about
this very specific issue because
everyone says you don't like government
go to Somalia I did I found nothing but
governments everywhere there's like four
governments and four governments
literally sending weapons and arms
everywhere the Middle Eastern government
at the Turkish uh the United States this
is a bit we got to do for cast castle
where it's like Luke's nightmare is ever
he like turns the corner and there's
like the people from the government ah
he turns around as a different
government government inspectors
licensing
but we are chained Somalia you could see
my adventures in Mogadishu uh and and
you could see uh you know all the
government that's there I can solve all
of the political violence in this
country simmer everything down it really
is easy government mandated chicken
ownership amen everybody's got to take
care of chickens and and you eat the
eggs no more buying Farm egg sorry Farm
businesses all your egg businesses are
gone because we're gonna have our own
chickens and what we're going to learn
from this is peace
yes right no no if if we really had a
caring and considerate government during
these these very difficult times during
these very hard financial times they
would be trying to incentivize personal
responsibility they would try to say hey
maybe you should get a chicken maybe you
should try to learn how to grow your own
food maybe you should try to have some
kind of livestock so you could actually
not be dependent on anyone because we're
not going to be there for you when we
screw you over that's it real quick but
I just want to point out you're you're
right on that one being personally the
point I'm really trying to make is
owning chickens what I really mean to
say is be responsible for the food you
eat source as much of your own life as
you can but I just want to add there is
nothing more heartwarming than walking
up to the coop and watching all of the
chickens waddle over to you because they
know you got food and it's hilarious it
is they're like goofy looking little
things in their jaws hanging their
mouths hanging open like morons but we
have active attacks on people who try to
teach
individual responsibility yeah you know
I mean just look at Jordan Peterson I
think you all were talking about this a
little bit yesterday but it's like they
attack him for no other reason and he's
just trying to help people be
self-sufficient and then they and that's
what teachers in schools used to teach
is teach kids how to be self-sufficient
here's a really interesting story I
think man but in I I found a
kindergartner test from uh from like
1983 and in order to be first of all you
were six almost seven years old going to
kindergarten back then and when one of
the line items on the test was you have
to be able to walk six blocks away from
your home go into the store buy
something and bring the money back with
correct change to your parents that was
something that you had to be able to do
to go into school now they want you you
know at three years old and this is what
I keep telling people at home in
Oklahoma because you know we're all gun
owners and I believe in Second Amendment
but the government is after your kids
and you they don't need your guns if
they have your children yeah and they
don't need your guns if you look at
what's happened in our society the
people who are being attacked the most
are the people who have the most Freedom
who has the most Freedom Farmers people
who are personally responsible for
themselves people who are living in the
middle of nowhere and don't need anyone
or anything they are the number one
targets the number one attack of our
current establishment and I think that's
being done for a reason guys I was I was
freaking out earlier today because there
was this story going viral about the uh
this New Zealand Jacinda ardern and
apparently she was calling for a
censorship and I got really scared and I
started you know sweating bullets and
I'm like what's what's happening is is
this information coming and then
thank you Newsweek published the fact
check did new zealands just send to
Arden call to censor Free Speech yes no
no thank you Newsweek for for correcting
the record it's false she didn't
actually call for censoring free speech
I was worried you know because this idea
that a world leader would be like we
should control the flow of information
really scared me but thank you Newsweek
for correcting the record and letting us
all know what really happened yeah let
me let me play the video just to make
sure everybody understands we're booting
it up here we got Twitter loading up
here we go we launched an initiative
alongside companies and non-profits to
help improve research and understanding
of how a person's online experiences are
curated by automated processes that's
not so bad right this will also be
important in understanding more about
Miss and disinformation online the
challenge that we must As Leaders
address
sadly I think it's easy to dismiss this
problem as one in the margins I can
certainly understand the desire to leave
it to someone else
As Leaders we're rightly concerned that
even the most light touch approaches to
disinformation could be misinterpreted
as being hostile to the values of free
speech that we value so highly see she
says we value Free Speech why is
everybody Reagan on this
picture today what the answer is to this
challenge I can say with complete
certainty that we cannot ignore it
to do so poses an equal threat to the
Norms we all value Norms after all how
do you successfully end a war
if people are led to believe the reason
for its existence is not only legal but
Noble no hold on there a minute I I
agree with that we were lied into the
Iraq War and when you tried coming out
and saying this was bunk and bunk BS we
shouldn't be there we're Afghanistan for
that matter nobody believed you and the
media kept lying about it well wait a
minute that's the corporate press that
did that that's the government oh yeah
that was that was former National
Security so uh what does she say how do
you tackle climate change if people do
not believe it exists
think about that here is a did you get
serious like this is a despotic speech
this is the the prime minister of New
Zealand saying if people don't believe
something exists you can't manipulate it
it's just remarkable because like
imagine going around as a government
leader insisting that we should take
action to stop the moon men from
invading Earth and you're like but why
doesn't anyone believe me when I tell
them the moon men are coming maybe
you're wrong maybe that's the insane
thing about it that right there is the
most important part of the speech it
shows you where these world leaders want
us to be
climate change is ideological now we can
talk about the science behind it that's
fine but there's a rift in politics as
to whether or not people think it is or
isn't happening we just had a video the
other day where Don Lemon tried pushing
a NOAA scientist into saying the
hurricane was was intensified by climate
change and he would not do it that's the
perfect example of what I'm saying I
think there there's climate change
issues I do but I certainly think when
Don Lemon is a zealot is like how is
climate gen affect affecting this and he
goes it's not and he goes well hold on
there a minute like I lived I grew up
there I think it is I think it is yeah
okay you're a zealot she's clearly
asserting here that she has an ideology
that she wants to persist and there is
an opposition to that ideology she does
not want to exist this is the underlying
message of what this psychopath is
saying we must address this issue yeah
the issue is they want to control what
you can think what you can hear and what
you can see and ultimately how you'll
end up voting because of it yeah the
speech gets worse as it goes on she
pretty much eludes that freedom of
speech is a weapon of War yeah she says
that dissenting voices are evil and
dangerous to her how do you ensure that
he the human rights of others are upheld
when they
when they're too hateful and dangerous
rhetoric and ideology okay that's not
disinformation or misinformation though
that's opinion but let's
the weapons may be different
but the goals of those who perpetuate
them is often the same
to cause chaos and reduce the ability of
others to defend themselves
to disband communities
to collapse the Collective Strength of
countries who work together
but we have an opportunity here to
ensure that these particular weapons of
war do not become an established part of
warfare weapons
it gets worse she's calling for a global
censorship effort is she saying that
often happens to feel
you're facing many battles on many
fronts
but there is cause for optimism
because for every new weapon we face
there is a new tool to overcome it
for every attempt to push the world into
chaos is a collective conviction to
bring us back good news we have the
means
we just need the collective will global
censorship effort this is the end game
that they're working on that they're
pushing for he or she is a globalist
world economic Forum Lackey and stewed
she has secret meetings with BlackRock
she locked down her entire country and
punished people for for political causes
during a national quote Health Emergency
when a few cases popped up she locked
down and destroyed people's livelihoods
just a few months ago and we cannot
forget that right now is dangerous and
it shows us where we're going Newsweek
says fake news Luke Newsweek says you're
wrong and I know I just listened to what
she said
but I see a little meter with a needle
pointing to the red ones
that's all you need can I take can I
take this home for just a second in fact
so I'm I'm in Oklahoma nobody nobody
looks at Oklahoma we got you know we got
two college football teams and that's
what people think of but the the
president of the University of Oklahoma
gave very much this same speech about
inclusive free speech at the University
of Oklahoma of saying that you know we
can't have free speech unless everybody
feels the same and thinks the same and
says the same things yeah and and so
that it's coming from the ground up and
from the top down and that's what we
have to start realizing and that's why I
really want people who are you know like
me out there in the trenches in these
states maybe nobody pays attention to
looking for this in their local media
looking for this in their in their
colleges and in their schools because
it's it's not just coming from leaders
of New Zealand or even the United States
it's coming from your local leaders from
your University leaders your school
leaders and and Your Business Leaders
even if the even average Point well this
is the gas lighting that that's
happening here like you saw what you
said uh it's totally fake news don't
worry just trust us again this is the
orwellian this is 1984. this is this is
what they're essentially after because
if they can control information they
know that they control people's minds
and the only thing standing in the way
of them subjugating and controlling
everyone is people just being able to
talk freely with each other that is the
biggest threat against their entire
Ponzi scheme which is their governments
and this is not just the local
government of New Zealand they are
working together on a global effort with
many leaders many prime ministers many
presidents many people behind the scenes
who are really controlling them saying
hey we're going to push this slowly and
surely and the end goal of what she's
calling for here is a global censorship
board that's internationally everywhere
applied to everyone on the face of this
Earth I want you to imagine a scenario
you're sitting down with uh someone
and uh pop on Twitter pops up this video
where Joe Biden says so I told him it's
uh it's sick what time is it six o'clock
if if everyone was like those times if
if the prosecutor's not fired by six
o'clock you're not getting the money
and well SOB guy gets fired and then you
sitting there
you say whoa did Joe Biden just quit pro
quo and the man next to you wearing the
suit says
Russia put that video out oh and then I
want you to imagine what like level of
cognitive ability you would have to have
to go uh
oh that that proves it this is just
phase one they're weeding out the people
that'll just believe the gaslighting
next it's going to be deep fakes where
even the intelligent people don't know
what's real well well already if if we
say that this happened the fact Checkers
are going to demote downrank our posts
delete our post delete our entire
accounts and our ability to even have a
voice on the internet and might even go
as far as to destroy our ability to earn
money which is centrally linked to of
course online centralized platforms like
like PayPal that legitimately do punish
people because of their political
opinions I want you to just imagine or
actually no there's a meme it's really
funny it's two people sitting down in a
post-apocalyptic world and he hands a
meme to the other guy and it's like you
know the meme exists well it's already
there but I'm saying there's a meme of
it yeah it's like he's got a physical
meme he's got a hand to somebody else
but I want to hit on something you
brought up because it takes an actual
process to get the mind to do what you
explain to have that guy in the suit the
expert tell you what that should not
believe what you see with your eyes
that's social emotional learning yeah
that's exactly what that is because you
train kids and you train people over a
course of time there are multitudes of
different ways even through the media
that you that you consume right and they
train you to respond emotionally because
you then feel wait a minute am I
offending this person then I better
agree with him and then agreeing with
him means it's altered my reality that's
social emotional learning and that's
what's happening in your schools right
now that's that's the whether you're
talking about anti-racism or you're
talking about diversity equity and
inclusion they all mean pretty much the
exact opposite of what they're saying
but they play upon the emotions to make
you feel a different way the end result
is go is that Liberals are are killing
their own kids and sterilizing them so
it's like
with the future if they if they get
control of the information systems I'm
still not convinced that
they will perpetuate their ideology
enough yeah I don't know I'm terrified
that that could happen like being kids
people being born into a system where
they don't where they're just being told
it'll be what will happen is the things
we know now can be erased from the
conscious memory they can be Rewritten
the digit of all the things can be
burned this stuff can be trans like we
probably were born into a system of
brainwashing without realizing it sure
oh Columbus sailed the ocean blue we're
the good guys and then you find out the
eradication of the genocide of the
population the all the horrors or is
that even real yeah exactly who knows
what who knows what is real you may be
no this is an important point just to
hit on that when you're like we hear
that Columbus did you know he came here
and discovered America or whatever
that's like oh okay that's really cool
then you learn later like actually he
genocided the Native Americans the
question is which which version of
history is the true version if one of
them is wrong how do you know which
one's the real one if either of them are
real right right we know Christopher
Columbus came over on a jet ski and like
just chill or even help me I grew up in
the United States just fine and if I was
if I was in some sort of fog intentional
up you know be made to believe lies and
stuff I was okay about it and I was
totally happy so I'm afraid that people
could grow up in this modern
technocratic society and experience the
same kind of thing and just go along
with a you know Free Speech not knowing
what that means or they'll still use the
term Free Speech but it will mean what
they want it to be redefined as the
freedoms you sacrifice now your children
will never know or practice it uh that's
a it's a famous quote I butchered it it
doesn't matter but what Jacinda over
here this this lunatic crazy insane
bureaucrat from New Zealand is calling
for is already happening in other parts
of the world in the United Kingdom if
you offend someone with your post and
someone sees it you go to Jail recently
a UK police officer arrested someone
because he called them a wiener head uh
but in a more unfamily unfamily family
show that's rough oh in a more
okay the censorship boards are already
uh I have to navigate it carefully here
how much worse can they get they're
talking about the potential end of
humanity well I mean saying the word
dick yeah
if we need to say like Express like yes
you know the algorithm also picks up
harsh language as well
but he has you know buddies and he he
repeats the and he gets demonetized
support you Phil so so so so again I
also want to be respectful to the
children out there and their families
out there but it's also a name but but
just to bring it back here what Jacinda
is calling for is already happening
she's just calling for it to be
implemented everywhere under the control
of one centralized body that will get to
arrest people for offending people
hurting their emotions and saying things
that the government
arbitrarily says well this is not
accepted now you go to jail she says
that people some the people will use
this tactic of putting knowledge out
that's fake basically lying and that
often they have do it for the reasons of
destroying an evil but she's very clear
that it's often it's not all the time
that's why you're innocent until proven
guilty if if you put out you can lie you
know you're allowed to lie and insult
people at least in this country you are
I want to talk the story from the Daily
Mail Bruce Willis sells rights to permit
deep fake digital twin of himself to be
created to for use on screen allowing
him to come out of retirement after
Aphasia diagnosis no he's not coming out
of retirement this is just the beginning
of what what should we call this we need
an era the Deep fake area Darkly area
Scanner Darkly earth look we were just
talking about how they you're not going
to know what's real yeah they're they'll
deep fake a video of you know Trump or
something and then people are just going
to believe it I was on Rogan's show uh
it was I think it was last year and he
asked me he's like are you worried about
the Deep fake stuff and I was like nah I
don't I don't think I'm not worried
about that because
you know people you're they're gonna
know where Trump is they're gonna know
where you know whoever the president is
they're going to know where they're at
and when they're speaking now that I'm
looking at it and I think I deeply
underestimated the abilities of deep
fake technology and this is just the
beginning a video will go viral and it
will be of President you know one two
three whoever and they'll say something
that won't sound too crazy but will be
worrying they'll say something like this
this is what you need to watch out for
you'll get a video of a president saying
we need to focus on our tax reduction
plan
and all they'll do is change reduction
to uh to you know incremental something
very simple to shift support away from
the person they'll say something like it
is true we're offering a one percent
income tax reduction and then they take
that video and deep fake increase and
then they send that out it goes viral
this is when I hear them say stuff like
you know we have to be concerned about
missing disinformation hey they're not
wrong that just send the order and being
like people will use misinformation I'm
like they will the problem is it's
primarily been coming from government
and major corporations so my fear is not
the random dude in his living room who
somehow gets access to a deep fake
generator or like a good one because
people can actually get these consumer
grade ones my concern is government or
military grade technology that can
generate deep fakes and then one day
you're an anti-war activist you're
you're saying Julian Assange and then
all of a sudden a video gets leaked
which is indistinguishable from from any
other normal video of you saying
something believable but reputation
damaging and you come out and say that's
a deep fake and people are going to be
like oh get Audi a conspiracy theorists
and then the media can run the video and
when you threaten a sue they'll say but
your honor we have a video of him saying
it and they're just going to be like can
you prove it's fake and they're gonna go
how do you prove it's fake it's a deep
fake and they're like either prove it's
a deep fake or it stands that's the
world we're entering and you know what I
gotta tell you we're there already we
are there now this story about Bruce
Willis this is entertainment I've heard
that people that government
organizations will like put files on
people's computer and then go get their
you oh you got child porn on your
computer
do you have a deep fakes too they call
as government mean to control the mind I
mean mint is like meant is meant to his
mind governed the the root of the word
is to direct or control it's a Rome it's
a Latin term it's just mind control I
mean that's the essence of government is
controlling people's thoughts well and
and it must be noted that the that
Jefferson the quote on the inside of the
Jefferson memorials I declare Eternal
hostility against any form of tyranny
over the mind of man and that they were
wanting to tear it down in 2020.
interesting that's all you know wow man
we also have to understand that this
technology also is developing at such a
very fast rate this is what's public
what is not public what don't we know
about and personally from my own
speculations and my own kind of thinking
about this if you could deep fake actors
and and certain videos you could
probably deep fake individuals you could
probably deep fake uh influencers you
could probably deep fake entire social
media accounts to pretend to be somebody
pushing an agenda that of course is
going to be making videos is going to
having you know the Selfies is going to
be of course broadcasting about
everything but everything's going to be
user computer AI generated to push a
certain idea to emotionally manipulate
you in a certain way that benefits a
multinational corporation or a private
entity in interest that of course
haven't in that that want to manipulate
you for their own personal causes who's
going to be doing that very powerful
people the Corp the the billionaires the
multinational corporate versions the
government the secret societies the
intelligence agencies all of the people
now saying hey you have increased
speeches bad we need to control all of
it which is an absurd idea and and and
what Ian is saying is is not too far
away from the reality it is trauma-based
mind control that a lot of people are
going through are unaware of it and this
is one of the main ways that they they
use to control people is with emotions
and now ai generated content creators I
think that's something that we should be
looking out for Ian is 100 correct meant
the uh that's the suffix comes from the
Latin Mente meaning mind yeah and then
govern is to steer drive or control oh
good to know there you go blatant and it
doesn't happen we're paying taxes to
that's not doesn't mean that's the
current government of the day who's the
current government of the day Google
alphabet they're controlling what we see
here and think I mean not directly but
indirectly no I think directly I mean
you you can opt in but not really I mean
go go go down the street I was at a
water park just just not too long ago in
the middle of Oklahoma and I went up and
I was like hey I need some quarters they
were like we're a cashless we don't
accept cash
you know what I mean and in order to do
that then okay well I've got a phone I
don't have my card you know maybe it's
in the locker or whatever you have to
opt in to the technology to be a part of
society now so I I I think it's
absolutely direct and it's pervasive and
it's becoming more and more pervasive in
not just the AI way or not just the Deep
fake way but in the every day I I've got
to feed my family you know go to school
kind of way that everyone deals with and
that's that's the real danger of this is
that it's it's a part of everyday life
so it's actually a Greek before Latin uh
kuberman and goober mare the the Greek
word Cooper this is what Google says for
etymology it was to steer and then in
Latin became guber mare which meant to
steer and Rule which led to old French
governor which was probably just
pronounced govern and then they added
meant of the mind so to steer and
control the mind meeting there you go
you learn you you what is it yeah no no
no the more you know the military yeah
the military certainly is used to
control your mind because it's the
threat of force that gets you to pay
your taxes and things like that
government
um but it's not that's not really the
man it's like a usurpation of global
governance happened in the last 20 years
and I'm you know we're waking up to it
the liberal International economy my
friend yes it was stripped by corporate
by alphabet like they without us
realizing it they just took control of
the narrative you guys have it what do
you got to do with it man it's amorphous
you know
there was a point where AOL was the
dominant digital Force but it wasn't
that powerful Because the Internet
wasn't that powerful and then AOL still
exists but I mean who talks about them
Yahoo still exists but come on alphabet
is insane and it's like 11 companies or
something yeah it's a black rock it's
the corporation yeah it's like just
welcome to the Sci-Fi dystopia where the
corporation and they're like yeah that's
why they called it alphabet they're
making fun of like uh NBC and CBS and
abs they're like yeah CIA FBI they're
like we're all of them man we are the
alphabet yeah that's wow that's creepy
that's one form of government is
alphabet but you have to wonder if
that's true and they're as powerful as
we as as many fear why would they allow
this show
is it because there's nothing we can do
to stop it well maybe but I think it's
also that inadvertently we hit points
all of us do in the because we actually
think we hit points that they like at
certain points and they think okay well
at this point we're going to allow it up
to this point because they're still
giving us what we want even though we
don't like most of what they're saying
and because we're free thinking people
right but at a certain point you get to
an Alex Jones or you get to a you know
uh another person like that or even
James Lindsay being taken off Twitter
the moment you hit it the too much they
take you down you know I'm telling you
you gotta get chickens you'd really
understand this right so we have I think
30 chickens outside and they're all
doing their chicken thing and it's fine
but we had a couple a couple roosters in
there and then when they start acting up
they get removed and sent to cocktown
the penal colony where all the rooster
boys
yeah because they're always fighting
fascinating they're always fighting and
so so the point is
I don't care what the chickens do at all
they can fight eat bang whatever but
when they step too far with it they get
removed so my view is maybe a show like
this they view similarly like hey yeah
they're all in their Coop doing their
stupid thing it's not it doesn't matter
to us we don't care but Alex Jones on
the other hand he was that loud
obnoxious rooster that wouldn't stop
screaming right and finally they were
like okay now now this rooster is
causing me problem I'm having a meeting
and it's screaming and squawking and
it's and now my the guy that said I'm
trying to sell to he leaves so say okay
we're taking them out and we're putting
them in the penal colony right once you
you will know when you've stepped out of
line well and and that has happened even
to a smaller you know I've got 20 20 000
Twitter followers but I'm working with a
with a group a guy named Alvin Louis of
Courage is a habit it's a great name
great organization to go look for it but
um he uh we we just under uncovered this
this kind of scandalous videos uh from
ASCA which is the American School Coral
American School Counselors Association
and within what is it 17 hours we all
both of us got uh banned from Twitter
from YouTube from from Amazon and from
Google and it was like we're nobody you
know I mean you guys have hundreds of
thousands of views that's why but we hit
something and then the next day the next
day
a video comes from the Federal
Department of Education just praising
school counselors it was amazing I'd
never seen anything like it and the
censorship targets the smaller accounts
because they don't make a ripple when
they're banned that's true so they're
pulling out you know look you get a big
thick hair and You Yank it out of
someone's head it hurts but you got a
little peach fuzz here you can pop them
up people don't feel anything that's
basically what this is they know that if
they ban bigger channels it creates
Ripples and it amplifies at least
temporarily and may you know what it's
saying you gotta roaches step on it the
eggs go flying everywhere or something
like that that's what they want to avoid
so they go for the smaller they they're
going for the Grassroots they're cutting
the roots at the core to eliminate the
support if you're banned from YouTube or
Twitter as a small follower then it's a
lot harder for you to follow along
interact with and support the person who
is speaking that's that's Twitter's
strategy well and that's it's happening
on YouTube too I mean I'm right now I am
more Shadow banned on Twitter than I've
ever been uh and and it's because of the
fight that we're having in Oklahoma
about these these hospitals in the trans
issue and it just got a little too close
to home and it's amazing to me to see it
because I just thought oh I'm small you
know I I've got a decent following for
the area but I'm small but you're right
they come after you because if they get
us you know and you have no Grassroots
you all can talk all you want in in
these bigger platforms but it's it's the
Grassroots that really makes the the
bottom-up change and so I don't know I
don't know what we do about that we we
have to start doing something well we
need to please ourselves from the bottom
up I think the corporation alphabet's
got it's balancing the heaviest Hammer
ever noticed by Humanity essentially
like intellectual hammer and and they
have 12 some of these common are you
have some of their companies Calico
human health company over overcome aging
Capital G's private Equity Deep Mind
does artificial intelligence Google
Google does internet services Google
fibers its own company uh GV is a
venture capital company intrinsic does
robotic software isomorphic Labs does
drug Discovery verily is a human health
company uh waymo is autonomous driving
Wing does drone based delivery and X
development is research in Dev for
moonshot they're taking us to space
these Technologies in the hands of a
private company are very very dangerous
if the private proprietary code is
alternative open sourcing the code so
that we at least know how to counteract
drones when they mount machine guns on
them and start hacking them and flying
them over you know uh cities and and
suburbs but like in a detrimental way
that's negative or illegal or a moral
and ethical uh what do you mean is
anything that could happen I mean you've
seen Terminator two the guy didn't know
he was building the Terminator while he
was building it it's propriety if when
this when you guys you're listening
right now the owners you guys had
alphabet when you sell the company the
next guy to get to that code has control
of the world you gotta free that's also
a lot of people who worked on the
nuclear bomb didn't know that they were
working on the nuclear bomb yeah a lot
of the scientists also regretted it
there's also a lot of cases of the
scientists who worked on it committing
suicide because of the guilt that they
felt building this but but to go along
with the point that started this
conversation if if resistance resistance
was futile they wouldn't need to censor
us and they are censoring us and there
are a lot of underhanded things that we
still don't even know about that happen
on YouTube on Twitter on Google on
Facebook on on MailChimp almost
everywhere online there are small
underhanded things happening that are
not as blatant that are not as big as
censorship and I think what we're seeing
here is is kind of like the boiling of
the Frog analogy slowly and surely
they're pushing for this but they know
that they can't move too quickly because
their whole agenda and their whole game
will be uncovered because it's
essentially the truth that will expose
it all and that's what they're afraid of
it's sous-vide is that what it's called
yeah the eggs no it's the the vacuum
slow cooking warm water oh yes let's see
the eggs version oh okay Starbucks yeah
yeah yeah you guys know what that is
yeah like you vacuum seal sous-vide you
vacuum sealed the meat and you put it in
the warm water for like 20 hours and
then it makes it like really tender or
whatever so that's what's happening
that's what happened to the human rights
we're not even boiling let me tell you
guys a story I was once playing World of
Warcraft on my laptop and I had it on my
lap this was
I know where this is going
where is it going oh it's about singing
leg hairs the hairs ever grow back
frying your eggs of course yeah tell me
more so I'm sitting Indian style so it's
being held up by my thighs on my left
and my right I'm sitting in bed and um
you know I'm just applying my laptop got
really hot when I took the laptop off
my left leg itched and I scratched it
and pulled skin right off the computer
was hot but only slowly and it burned me
blistered and I didn't notice because it
happened so slowly when I put the laptop
on my on when I was sitting with my
laptop it was cold after playing for a
couple hours it was really really hot
and constantly on my skin and I didn't
feel any pain and it was a small blister
that I ended up I itched and pulled it
right off well and part of that was too
your mind was so focused on something
else so it just removed all the
sensation from the other parts of your
body and all the blood rushing to that
that neuro you know the the the dopamine
and stuff you're getting from the game
it removes feeling from the rest of your
body and it fries your balls and many
doctors are saying that it actually has
a very bad impact on on male sperm sperm
counts so when people are heavily
focused on energy helps on their
desensitized yeah they become
desensitive because when you're focused
on something that isn't real
and it makes you know it makes the it
makes the real less real Faraday cage
underwear yeah yes oh that's a good idea
although with all the you know Warfare
against the balls
Faraday cage uh fanny pack put my phone
in there when I walk around yeah it
doesn't irradiate my nuts I have a
faraday cage like pouch that my dad sent
me because he's like you're paranoid too
here's a parody cage for your phone I
should get one of these
in there yeah we should call the company
and say can you make underwear they
should sponsor my money and we can make
the underwear the clothing in general it
doesn't work because
um it has to be close so I'll give you
an example the tin foil hat thing
actually has the inverse effect it
amplifies yeah because the signals can
still enter from underneath through your
body now water does block a lot of this
you need a one-way mirror you need a
full Faraday suit so it can block every
part so if you want to walk around you
ever see those faradays they're really
cool yeah if you want to walk around in
that I guess or when it can get out but
it can't get in so it'll sneak in the
corners and then can get work its way
back out we should just build Outlook we
should build a triple layer Faraday cage
just to do it and film it and like we we
should do one big one a small one and
then inside the so there's a big one you
can walk in then another one inside that
and then there's a box and so we can see
at what point the cell phone stops we
were actually planning on building that
where do you want to do it do you
understand okay you think we should
start construction soon let's do it
before it's too cold yeah we could
probably whip that up pretty quick and
then I mean in in reality we probably
want to put it indoors somewhere yeah
for sure because now we could store
stuff in it yeah that'd be cool yeah
basically
so the old prepper trick is to is to put
a microwave like in deep storage and put
a phone in a laptop in it but it's like
unplugged obviously you know I don't
think that freeing telling alphabet
corporate execs to free the code is is
sensical enough I know you guys think
like come on Ian that's like that's just
such a hitting it with a sledgehammer I
know you can't just give it give it all
away it's not but at some point I mean
if you are trying to hold on to this
power it's gonna obliterate your hand
and then it's gonna consume us like we
can't no no sector group of us can do
this alone
only only beings of extraordinary
strength could wield such power I mean
if if somebody were to hold this then
powerful bursts of purple energy light
would emit from their hand and then they
would scream and explode and it would
just be damaged but a true defense a
group of people that are close and
friends could hold each other's hands
and temporarily contain that power just
enough to defeat Ronan oh I'm going to
start doing a meditation a group
meditation if you guys want to join me
at 2PM tomorrow uh I'll be meditating
I'll be doing it for at least five
minutes and if you want to jump in right
at 2 p.m Eastern Standard Time I think
that the power of good needs to organize
what are you going to focus on nothing
empty mind
and let it happen and you can meditate
there are some very interesting studies
about big meditation groups focusing on
one thing and helping
um actually bring those things forward
well that's the scientific case for
prayer yes you know what I mean the the
prayer meditation
when you focus you know and you can have
whatever focus on your intentions yeah
yeah or just focus towards a result but
if you do it from the the standpoint of
God or or wherever you do it it
obviously hasn't it's my backfire by
giving me an idea look at his eyes
I got it we want to make sure that
everybody's listening who does do the
group meditation with Ian that they have
the intention of something good and
Noble yeah so I think tomorrow at 2PM
when everyone begins to meditate they
should all focus on aliens coming to
Earth no no no no no no no no no no but
hold on you're gonna look at us they're
like Kamala Harris Joe Biden are your
leaders of the Free World we're taking
yeah get it get it out of here make sure
you denote time zone yeah this world is
a brand it's a joke on all of life in
the universe we gotta get rid of it
focus on whatever you want I trust you
we I think it's going to work itself out
as long as we're all working on this
team no no no no no don't listen to him
everyone focus on Ian getting ripped
yeah there you go don't make me get
ripped and finally working out okay I'm
getting ripped I'm gonna start working
out and right after the meditation so
inspired something just overtakes Ian's
body yeah and he gets up he's like
what's happening I'm walking to the gym
no I'm picking up the weights we tried
this in 2007 on stickem.com but the
software wasn't good enough to get more
than like 15 of us in a chat room and
the software crashed when we had like 40
or 80 people and they're trying to
meditate I don't think we need to need
to be in the same room in the vicinity
you know with this high frequency
long-range communication of video chat
but we can we will do that later
tomorrow is going to be you and yourself
and whoever else wants to join you and
peace I I really do think everyone
should focus on Ian getting ripped yeah
let's do it okay not like because you
know Ian would be overcome tomorrow
because you know what is soldier fit
coming tomorrow can we
um I gotta get it get back to him we got
to talk to Danny Danny our awesome
Soldier fit uh and uh Ian you had many
offers to work out with me well 3 P.M
I'll be on pop culture crisis on uh that
doesn't help why don't you do Thursdays
do Thursdays and Friday will be our
workout day oh I love we should pick a
workout day we'll both be there because
last time you you you ditched oh no no
no don't you put it on me yeah you put
it on me I'm like the trainers here
let's go look and then you're like no my
hair is going to be wet I don't want my
hair
I'm knocking at your door or you're
sleeping the whole time come on that's
why we need everyone listening at 2PM to
all meditate give it five minutes and
just imagine Ian lifting weights you
have to meditate on Tim taking off the
beanie
everyone imagines it you know what he
looks like in a black hole I'm over here
trying to get
it let's go to super chats peace
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up at 11 p.m and uh share
the show be the notification a lot of
people are mentioning that uh they're
not getting notifications some people
are saying they're starting to get them
again but we're about a month after the
midterm so surprise surprise weird
things are starting to happen you can
prevent all of that or you can counter
it by simply sharing the video and
notifying others I've started tweeting
out the video I didn't used to do that
but clearly I have to be the
notification as well
all right I am says
look up man computer symbiosis it's a
paper from MIT in 1960 and it's where
all the big Tech ideology began one year
member here today too hey thanks man
appreciate the support
collisionikov says draft all the pro-war
Democrats to go fight hey I'm in favor
of a constitutional amendment that says
if you vote in favor of War you go fight
it because then we'd have no war let the
politicians fight it politicians want to
war go ahead go fight it I'm no
senator's son
says hey Tim today is my wife's
Britney's birthday and decided to do my
first Super Chat to wish her a happy
birthday we are also expecting our first
child enjoy the content and keep up the
awesome work nice
happy birthday happy time waffle Sensei
says Luke tell tell him Putin tell him
Putin that if he ends the war you'll let
him see the milkers or maybe even cop a
feel you're our only hope I appreciate
your optimism I'm polish though so
there's a bit of a odd you know
interaction there that would probably
happen even though we look like each
other true Christian Gemma guccian says
I find it interesting that the one time
the stream isn't about the culture war
is the one time I get a notification
about the stream
interesting it could be the extra uh you
know it could actually be that in the
algorithm the people who work for the
higher ups at Google prioritize talk of
war and conflict with Russia that makes
sense under the idea that like if we
just promote people talking about war
with Russia it will work towards us no
matter what the angle is or they're just
seeing how how Brave and Bold I am and
they're like that's good we like you
yeah
being his true self yeah thank you
okay we're looking with your best glutes
vosh says so while you sit back and
wonder why I got this effing Thorn on my
side oh my God it's a mirage I'm telling
you it's sabotage interesting like a
Beastie Boys song yes yes
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim let's not
forget that the broken brain admin
revokes Trump's order to stop buying
systems and parts for our electrical
grid from China they can sabotage our
bulk power system from 6 000 miles away
that they can
yeah that's crazy jeez man
cyber warfare people you won't even know
like there could be like an oil refinery
blowing up or like a food market
Catching Fire and you wouldn't know if
it was a accident or an act of sabotage
true unless they want you to know it's
kind of hard to find right
jammumi says first time I've actually
got a notification and was able to join
at the start and oh boy did it start
with a bang long time viewer
I remember Tim at 300K I appreciate
everything you all do hey appreciate it
thank you thank you for the support so
many so many awesome members become a
member at timcast.com
we're uh we're launching a new show with
Shane Cashman he has Tales from the
infinite World which it takes like a
year to to work out the full series
which is I think this one's like 13
parts and it's like it's like a true
crime mystery narrative storytelling Arc
the new show we're launching is going to
be starting weekly I believe it's gonna
be once a week and it's a live
conversation around Unsolved Mysteries
paranormal murder Etc so a lot of these
same ideas but sitting in an actual
setting if you guys see what we've been
doing with our other shows like pop
culture crisis what happens on pop
culture crisis if you should subscribe
if you haven't is that every time a
super chat comes in money guns fire 20s
into the air whatever I think that's 20s
right yeah and then whenever the the
crisis meter fills up air horns go off
Sirens go off in a bunch of money that's
flying like crazy what we're doing with
Shane's show is that whenever uh super
jets come in there's a combination of
thunder lightning storms wind and then
whenever a hundred thousand super jets
comes in a thunderstorm will actually
play low in the background as they talk
about ghost stories and Mysteries and
things like that
yeah nice
all right soy Jack pointing memes says
have you guys ever considered asking
Oliver Stone on the timcast on timcast
IRL he seems like someone you could get
and his geopolitical knowledge would
make for a great conversation especially
now I I interviewed him before he
provides very interesting perspectives
especially when it comes to Venezuela
which I disagree with him on but I think
his perspective would be interesting to
have a good conversation about it is a
dream of mine to argue with him about
the Kennedy assassination oh that'd be
great
yeah he went and interviewed Putin like
within the last couple years I think
yeah he interviewed Putin he made the
JFK movie
yeah I would love to have that
conversation because I went from
conspiracy theorists to not so much
interesting and so I would love to have
that and how much did they pay you oh
yeah I wish man they don't pay me
nothing I promise you that all right
Thomas tjg says what if China sabotage
the pipelines to escalate things over
there while they set themselves up for
something big that's a very good point
yeah yeah and so NATO is like we don't
know you know if you did this and then
Russia's like they did this in China's
like that's what I was saying earlier
there I said that to Lydia well that's
why it seems very China yeah that's why
I said it might not be a government it
could be an independent independent
organization that did this could it
could it be uh environmental terrorism I
mean could they not like the the the the
gas and the flowing of energy throughout
they want a clean energy agenda ESG
could be Coretta thumberg could be she's
very did she Greta and her frog men
I love regret it's like everyone's
making fun of her and she's acting all
dumb but then it's like you know she's
in private she's with these guys SEAL
Team Six we're going in this is how
we're going to do it it's a device Adam
Noel says Tim have you ever seen star
girl on CW it is literally one of the
best superhero shows ever made and it
displays anti-woke conservative values
I'm not even kidding at all star girl a
plus I I watched the star girl on HBO
Max I think it was I enjoyed it you know
it's like I don't know superhero show I
wouldn't say I I can't remember it to be
honest but I I mean compared to She-Hulk
you still watching it no I couldn't do
it after the it's been just like it
started with a c plus then it was like a
c minus then it was a d plus and now
it's F and I'm like I'm out it's that
bad and it's funny because they're like
if you don't like it you're an Intel or
the show is just bad calm down
like they're not even doing what they're
trying look you want to make a comedy
lawyer show I'm down it's fine but you
can't take the MCU and then create this
comedy lawyer show for it makes no sense
it doesn't work
I don't know what they were thinking man
it's like she's a Superhero and she
fights but it's a comedy in a courtroom
and we have no idea how the law works
apparently not okay
like they did an episode where
you know the Titania is using the name
She-Hulk and they have to sue over it
and I'm like this is the stupidest thing
it would be a summary judgment the judge
would be like oh you're wasting my time
like you can't use someone else's name
it was on TV get out of here but that's
where they want the law to go
you know so
you gotta mirror it if you want to see
it Bill Hughes says Russia only owns 51
of the pipeline who could be behind the
Nordstrom pipeline sabotage Washington
Examiner yes uh that's true but it's
it's a Russian point of Leverage because
they deliver through it so that's why
it's like why would Russia do this to
their own pipeline yeah they already
shut off one pipeline the yamal pipeline
because the Germany wouldn't accept it
in uh and it wouldn't pay in Rubles so
they could just shut it off just like
they did the other ones but doesn't it
hurt Germany the most the this this
shutting down of this pipeline it was
already shut down it was shut down in no
August no I'm talking about the the one
that was just yeah there was no
streaming it was known stream too right
okay okay but it is it's an attack on
Germany as well right right that's what
I was thinking it is yeah Germany relies
on over 50 of its natural gas and energy
from Russia it's an attack on German
infrastructure what has Germany owned
the other 49
um I'm not sure about those exact
details well if whoever owns that thing
was an attack on those countries
Philip R says formal invite for gensaki
to come on the Pod would be great I
think the Canadian trucker Hong Kong
meme I think for Tim for the crystal
flute okay
having gen Zak on the show would be
fantastic thank God I mean she was
brutally honest uh recently when she
talked about Democrats in the midterms
she she outright she basically says we
are targeting Republicans as extremists
because that's the path to victory for
Democrats she just said it I'm like well
now that she's not in the white house
she's just telling it like it is I guess
I mean I think she's wrong and I think
it's a horrible thing but you know I
think you see that a lot from a lot of
the press secretaries when they leave
they have to try to regain some
credibility you know what I mean and so
they go out and they're brutally honest
about the most obvious things so they
can you know so people can trust them
again because when you're in that job
your whole job is just to say just like
we've seen with John Pierre it's it's
you have to say some crazy stuff and
Kojima fire says Tim I regret to inform
you that the Satan II missile is not
Russia's most powerful nuke that title
goes to the Poseidon a nuclear-powered
torpedo that is autonomous and has a
yield of 100 megatons
yowza wow
so where we are right now we're
basically in Harpers Ferry if a 100
Megaton bomb hit DC we would be caught
in the Fireball and like people don't
know Harper's fair is like an hour and a
half away from DC that is a tremendous
blast radius that's just if it hits the
ground is the air burst no error air
burst yeah ground bursts don't spread as
much they they air burst all of them
just blankets the ground
I guess ground burst results in more
um
after aftermath I guess like it stays in
the soil it like stays on the ground and
then starts rising up and spreading
around
whereas Air Bursts it's in the air so
it's already up and spreading around
so it like lingers in a concentrated
area I don't I don't know maybe I'm
wrong
OMG puppy says the neocon goal is to
maintain U.S Global dominance and halt
the formation of a pan-Asian economic
block and prevent a multi-polar world
order
that's why wouldn't they get Russia and
China involved that's what I don't
understand if they want to prevent
multi-polar worlds why not become a
unipolar world and work together well if
that was the strategy they would be
trying to divide China and Russia
against each other and playing them up
so in a way where they would be fighting
each other we're not doing that we're
doing policies that are bringing them
together which is dangerous AV weasel
says I want to see Alex Jones as press
secretary that would be wild and
hilarious to see agreed or Michael
malice well if Michael Mouse is press
secretary he could have Deputy for
secretary Alex Jones oh yeah take a
night off yeah take the night off or you
could just bring him out yeah like you
can bring whoever you want for the press
conference Obama did that once with Bill
Clinton he was having a rough time at it
he's like you know here here's here's
bill you know everything about the 90s
yeah let's take it back for a minute and
you talk about the economy Southern
drawn just you know Alex Jones standing
up there wow
they'll be like
um Mr Deputy press secretary uh Dave
Smith the president is withdrawing our
troops in Afghanistan don't you think
this is dangerous I think you're a
globalist
and you want war
I'm like uh I'm I'm a reporter
that'd be awesome it would just be
screaming back and forth I love it yeah
they wouldn't even get any questions in
the podium and yelling
I'll tell you about CNN you want
reported one and they they'd be like uh
yeah Nobody ends up showing up so it's
just a live stream of Alex
and all of a sudden he's re-platformed
honestly those could be they could just
have like Twitter questions and then you
know Kareem Jean-Pierre could just take
like 15 Twitter questions and just say
it they don't need people in the
audience dude asking questions
have become I mean what do they take 15
Twitter questions if if you thought the
reaction to Donald Trump when in the
presidency was bad imagine what will
happen if Dave Smith wins the presidency
you're gonna get the Republican and
Democrat leadership being like he's
secretly a communist Nazi fascist uh
Alien was like imagine what they would
say about it baby kicker yeah
they'll be the fakes of like Dave like
with a bag of babies like throwing them
off a bridge that's ridiculous crazy
nonsense because you know even with
Trump
they didn't like him because it was
America first policy but Trump was not
some guy who was going to be like
anti-interventionist right like I I
don't want to say you know
he definitely did some good things in
terms of the Abraham Accords the peace
agreements and those were things that
they really did not like
but Dave Smith's attitude towards all
this is that Trump was still bad so
imagine him getting an office with
everything he would want to do in terms
of rescinding all of this uh
interventionist policy uh they their
heads would explode he was saying Trump
gave a bunch of weapons to Ukraine that
even Obama wouldn't give to the Ukraine
because he was afraid of inciting Russia
Trump is just like whatever no but
that's not it it was Russia is going to
move in if they can and if we make moves
before it we can prevent it from
happening if if the if Joe Biden
declared a no-fly zone over Ukraine
before The Invasion Russia would not
have been able to invade without
declaring war on us and and they called
Trump crazy for doing things like that
but I want to just say one thing
Eisenhower did the same thing he used to
say I will use nuclear weapons at any
given point that I want and this is
Dwight Eisenhower and because of that
and from 1952 to 1960
absolute peace because they thought he
was just crazy enough to do it and
that's why we had four years of peace
with Trump you know we need we need a
video of trump sitting at his desk with
a burrito and it's like imagine this the
camera angle is on the desk slightly
pointed up and he's just eating with one
hand
and then he has one finger over the butt
that says nuke Russia and he just looks
at the camera very slowly while he bites
the burrito and they just 15 minutes do
something like that where he's and then
he drops the burrito
yeah but wasn't there something like
that I just saw that was real where they
said uh he threatened a Taliban leader
by showing him a picture of their house
yeah something like that yeah
that is base he's probably just you know
slid it right on over he's like yeah you
know but but you take what you want from
that okay guys you take what you want I
just want to stress that like the the
point of that video is that Putin's
gonna be like okay I get it I get it
yeah no war no war like you know that's
true but I think under Trump the reason
why Putin didn't invade was twofold one
Trump was not interested in expanding
NATO Authority into Eastern Europe and
Putin kind of was worried that Trump was
nuts right might press the button well
it's that that unpredictability in a
leader is not a bad thing geopolitically
it can keep things peaceful well we've
seen that at least in two times in the
last 70 years the 50s and during Trump's
Administration but but it's important so
we don't we still don't know exactly
what happened behind the scenes with the
Trump Administration we have that story
yeah we have we have that with
Eisenhower uh but we still don't know
what's going on here and uh Trump even
made comments a couple of days ago
saying that the threat of War World War
Three is keeping him up at night yeah
but he's not there to stop it you know
what I'm saying that that's part of it
how did he stop it we don't know yeah
but there's a lot of bravado there's a
lot of PR we don't know what happened
here but but yeah we need to we need to
someone to draw like a manga style comic
of like a manga of trump and then like
Russia fires the nuke and then Trump
catches it with a single hand and he's
like holding it back as it's like and
then he goes Super Saiyan and then
throws it back at Putin Putin's like no
all right here we go bent knee record
says why are you silent on the Iran
protests the women of Iran are risking
their lives to call for Freedom against
a religious fanatic dictatorship they
deserve your attention
amen that's true
um I suppose it's because
there's a lot of things happening we
just we prioritize what we think you
know typically is the big news but I
will also say you know absolutely I
agree and respect to them it's not the
first time something like this has
happened so I guess what happened from
what I've heard is that a 22 year old
girl wouldn't wear her hijab and so the
the moral morality police is that what
they're actually officially called the
Iranian morality police they grabbed her
put her in a van beat her to death yeah
there's another story what's the other
side uh it's hard to believe but but
it's also important to note here there
are some protests that are promoted and
some that are completely ignored but
when you see the corporate media the U.S
government responds to this they're
always in it is it agenda yeah
it's a revolution in Iran yeah I I think
I think it's very interesting that there
usually Iran will stop this very quickly
that that's something that anytime
there's been an uprising like this other
than when the Ayatollah took over itself
since then like the CIA right right
right yeah since then uh any Uprising
that has just barely started gets
immediately pushed down and now I'm
seeing pictures of shirtless women
standing in front of religious things
people should have freedom and yeah oh
we should absolutely but but I think
what you're saying is that let's just
watch it for a minute and make sure that
this is all in the up and up and and
support those who need supporting but
you know well I would support any
protest against any government that's
true but yes
um at the same time we got to understand
that there's bigger things at hand here
being played that are manipulating the
situation all right Chandler Lee says Mr
ousley you're my choir teacher in 7th
and 8th grade at BMS I'm glad to see
you're doing well good sir
what's that Chandler Lee all right how
you doing brother what's good oh about
uh that's Blackwell Middle School oh
yeah so this is Blackwell Oklahoma so
very small Awesome Town Home of The
Maroons do you like teaching choir yeah
that's awesome yeah yeah that's it I
miss choir I miss teaching choir but you
know I'm out here maybe the fight maybe
I can go back to it one day only ever
wanted says looks like secret Invasion
isn't just a new Marvel series coming
soon with China exposed running secret
police in U.S and Canada
yeah we didn't get into that story oh
yeah crazy maybe we could talk about it
tomorrow yeah China's got 50 in Europe
three in Toronto and one in New York
their secret Chinese police to police
former and and current citizens abroad
yeah that's what the official statement
mission statement but the only Chinese
people are going to be affected like the
fact that a foreign government has Law
Enforcement operating secretly on our
soil is a it's
we're being colonized and invaded But
the United States also does that as well
then it has many branches outside of the
United States working internationally
everywhere as well that's creepy man so
they're just copying what we're doing
Noah rasban says I will not stand for
the disgusting and uneducated Godzilla
slander from last night Andrew needs to
educate himself on real film before
speaking ooh spicy and it's a Gojira
yeah it was because uh the Japanese one
they're saying Gojira Andrew's not a fan
and then Americans thought that they
were saying with an accent Godzilla um
saying gojiro no he just said something
like there were a ton of how many
Godzilla movies have there written so
far I am not a fan
I don't like giant fighting robots and
monsters or any of that stuff Pacific
Ram Voltron was cool yeah it was because
of five and one what I do what I do
really want to see and I think
I think I can unify the left and the
right and the culture War I think it
could bring World Peace would be if uh
Dom in Fast and the Furious 10 gets
superpowers and they introduce her
powers into the Fast and the Furious
Cinematic Universe and then maybe even
the Multiverse you know maybe maybe uh
travel other planets you know I'm open
but you know just think Vin Diesel fly
around with laser eyes like Superman uh
that's that's that would unify the world
okay yeah yeah we need more fourth
dimensional activity yeah in and out
let's go whoa pulsing whoa
let's grab some suggestions the music
Canon says Tim thank you for defending
the flute yesterday if we don't put a
stop to the desecration now it will be
the same as when they went after statues
a few years ago hate for them to go
after an artifact of bigger value there
it is it's very much like the uh
desecration of the statues the word I
was looking for is degradation yeah I
said desecration but uh the the moral
Foundation is sanctity degradation uh
degradation so sanctity is basically
like you value
um you you have a value to the to the
icons and the symbols of of your country
of your ideas of your history of your
people and for me the issue with the
flute is that it was specifically an
ornamental unplayed flute and they
brought it on stage for this this
clown show look I got I don't I have no
disrespect towards lizzo's music or
anything like that I'm just saying like
her taking the flute tooting it while
twerking is it was like an unserious
for what purpose was it done she didn't
play a song with it for the crowd she
just was handed it and then
degraded it it is no longer an
ornamental unplayed flute it is now a
spectacle for a lizzo concert and what
they're saying on Twitter
they're saying the leftists this is what
you do after you conquer your uh after
conquering your enemy you humiliate them
yeah that's their that's their that's
their idea that's how they feel about
this and progressivism progresses well
it's different than someone taking and
peeing on it but I mean it was a
flautist well that but that's the point
it's incremental if it's always
progresses a little by slowly but it
only takes you know a chip a chip a chip
and then there's a crack in the dam and
then it breaks you know it's it's it's
like bankruptcy yeah a little boy solely
and then all at once here you hate says
invite the last podcast on the left guys
on
um I I've heard of that but I'm not
familiar with what what it is what is it
is it a leftist podcast or is that just
a name I imagine they are I'm not sure
the first podcast on the right yeah that
would be us no I don't know no
yeah I don't know what they do yeah
Wyatt caldenberg says Tim can you get
Mike Benz from foundation for freedom
online on the show I saw him on TV and
he is really sharp on internet
censorship issues
who's that Mike Benz from foundation for
freedom online I'll write that down
Kaiser says Tim your deep fake story is
the setup to the anime dead man
Wonderland
interesting Matt Cali says James Earl
Jones also retired and signed his Darth
Vader voice rights over to AI to Disney
right yes he did yes he did yeah they
bought him out they bought his voice
here's the coolest thing here's the
coolest thing it's gonna be a thousand
two thousand years Earth is going to
look exactly as it does aliens are going
to show up and they're going to come
down and there's gonna be people running
around doing stuff and they're going to
be like oh we found a civilization of of
you know people and then they're going
to find out that there's no real people
they're all just AI
imitating human thoughts and behaviors
on a loop with no goals and no no
meaning no path
and it's just like AI replicas of James
Earl Jones welcome 50 of them 50 Bruce
willises
I'm thinking if corporations start
offering people money to the rights to
their person for the rest of Eternity
and people be like well I'm so desperate
that okay and then they'll take these
contracts and then all of a sudden the
money will become worthless and they'll
be like uh I want and they'll be like
sorry to sign the contract but didn't
you know we couldn't control the value
of the money well an Elvis
impersonations was the first part of
this you know he he sold his image oh
right right yeah I mean it's like have
you have you guys played stray no no
it's the game where he plays the cat
yeah that game's amazing yeah part of me
wishes that like it was a lot longer but
I get I think it's like an indie game
but it's basically it's it's when I
first heard about it it's like you play
as a cat doing cat stuff and I was like
but then you actually figure out what
the game's really about it's about
post-apocalyptic world and there are
robot helpers spoiler alert for anybody
who doesn't want to learn this stuff but
I'm going to mention it so the game's
been out for a little while
there are these robots that are walking
around doing stuff and originally they
were just helper AI Bots that would do
what humans told them to do but after a
really long time with humans being gone
they slowly started to evolve and adapt
their Ai and become more human-like and
so you know it's a it's a it's a really
cool game I feel like we should have
Graham Hancock on the show someday I
don't know if you know him Luke have you
worked with graham uh I haven't no he's
talking about Atlantis he talks a lot
about Atlantis has been for a long time
and uh that he was great he would be
awesome yeah the Deep dive they didn't
wear their you know their wealth with
modesty they basically became gratuitous
and and I think maybe we might be seeing
that in modern society absolutely
Steve Graves radio says YouTube is
heavily suppressing content that
discusses the climate agenda it is so
discouraging trying to grow my channels
at the center of the mainstream
establishment narrative I would be
honored to get a sub from timcast and we
are change shout out to Steve Graves
radio ideas should be allowed if you
cannot defeat look if there's some dude
on YouTube with like a thousand subs and
he's like I think the world is flat and
you're like oh no our ideas can't defeat
this person then you've got bad ideas
yeah and you've got bad spokespeople and
you need to focus on how you can easily
debunk things like Flat Earth
yo it's crazy that people think the
Earth is flat I just it's it's my no
it's like an indication of social Decay
for sure yeah why would you revert to
some 2 000 year old weird it's not even
it's not a 2000 year old fantasy it
never happened humans never thought the
world was flat
must have been ancient humans were like
they didn't know any different because
they're walking on what they think it's
like a psyop with the Messiah but they
were thinking about it because they saw
the boats on the horizon go down and
they went oh it's round and then it was
uh aristotenes I believe it was it was
the guy and they uh measured the the
towers uh Shadow angle or whatever and
then like did the math there's a guy who
watched uh who's a flat earther said
it's impossible to have actually
measured the Shadows from great distance
because how would he have communicated
and I'm like
he told the guy
go over there and then measure the
shadow at this point in time and I'll go
over here and do it we'll see if they're
different because they weren't that far
away dude you got to pull up a picture
of aristoceny's profile because he is
the definition of big brain big brain
this dude has a big brain wow brilliant
man
let's grab let's just do a couple grab
one more Phantom Walker access Tim cast
member from Austria here just want to
say hope you guys can still turn that
ship around for all of us
yes Delta one more Delta 99 report card
says Fast and the Furious and Speed
Racer crossover equals world peace I'm
down
um just kick it up a notch everybody hey
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member over at timcast.com
because we got a particularly spicy
members only show uncensored coming up
it's talking about uh I can't say too
much because YouTube isn't is it doesn't
like not to talk but uh it's gonna be
it's going to be good head over to
timcast.com sign up and again smash that
like button you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at timcast
Mark you want to shout anything else oh
yeah the unvocable podcast you can find
me on YouTube you can find me on sub
stack on multiple.substep.com I'm also
starting a little organization called
fathers defending daughters you can find
me at give sent go
um and yeah thank you for having me here
really appreciate it it's doing great
thank you so much for coming my YouTube
channel is youtube.com forward slash we
are change AOC got nothing on me watch
out alex99 and two days ago I did a
video specifically on Victoria Newland
it is definitely worth the watch she has
her hand in Ukraine for a very long time
you youtube.com forward slash we are
change see you there your uh your
Jersey's a little wrinkled wrinkled yeah
I just want to watch you
watch you I know you do
I
know
yeah
um for Fast and Furious Speed Racer goes
so fast that he breaks through the time
space barrier and warps through
Dimensions Landing next to Vin Diesel or
whoever's in the movie and now you've
got a cross or you just got to get the
rights I want to remind you that at 2
p.m tomorrow Eastern Standard time I'll
be meditating in a deep trance for at
least five minutes and I'm gonna let it
roll as long as I feel you do the same
be there with me in the in The Ether and
I'll see you there at three o'clock
tomorrow p.m Eastern Standard time I
will be doing pop culture crisis on
YouTube check it out pop culture show on
Twitter I'll see you then well Ian has
busy schedule for tomorrow afternoon you
guys should all join him in wishing him
to do whatever you want him to do and
see if it works you guys can follow me
on twitterminds.com
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys